salut tout le monde si vous voulez louer
le studio sf pour faire votre propre
podcasts ou pour objet d la qualité de
votre podcast c'est possible écrivez
nous à sans filtre podcast at gmail.com
vous venez ici le service et tout
compris vous avez la vidéo vous avez le
son qu'on vous donne suite après votre
enregistrement
yann nicol qui va être là pour vous
servir pour vous accompagner dans cette
aventure
le studio sfr assure que la qualité est
optimale à tous les niveaux et puis pour
ramener votre projet le niveau c'est
vraiment la bonne chose à faire
alors écrivez nous fera plaisir de vous
recevoir ici une production du studio
sfr nous sans filtre le podcast où on
parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos invités
date si tu cherches quentin
habituellement avec moi d'une plante le
lait chaud on recommence effet que deux
mi-temps guigue à québec
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par un obe nerfs en fait dans les
mesures qu'on a pris pour essayer de
mettre en valeur des obnl ou des
entreprises qui oeuvrent dans la lutte
sociale en fait on a reçu quelques mails
dont un de sarah abélard qui est une
jeune haïtienne de montréal qui a lancé
un obnl qui s'appelle yong imf loin
d'eux of today qui est une initiative en
fait qui premier leur premier projet
c'est de vendre des masques sur lesquels
s'est inscrit blake lively madère et ses
masques le tous les profits vont à et
des trois organismes qui viennent en
aide à la communauté noire donc la
maison d'haïti
le black grosse cote et solutions note
punishment en ce moment on sait que le
port du masque est rendu pratiquement
obligatoire voire est très recommandé
dans les lieux publics
donc c'est parfait pour démontrer votre
support à la cause black rider
vous pouvez aussi sur leur site web
faire des donations de 15 dollars qui
vont servir enfants acheter des masques
à des gens qui ne peuvent pas s'acheter
masque donc c'est vraiment une super
initiative un super projet vous allez
voir le site cm full web today
- org le site web s'cusez moi je regarde
mon cela parce que les informations
m'arrive en ce moment donc in france tu
des points org
à les voir aller voir sur puis merci
beaucoup sarah nous avoir écrit puis si
vous êtes propriétaire ou si vous
connaissez une obnl qui oeuvre à la
justice sociale
écrivez-nous pis on va faire des
charades comme sur le temps en temps sur
notre podcast notre humble façon de
d'utiliser notre tribune en fait sinon
cette semaine sur le podcast
on a reçu pour la deuxième fois gabriel
nadeau-dubois galerie on l'avait reçue
le deuxième podcast succès depuis le
jour 1 vous allez vous en rappelez j'ai
réécouté justement le podcast puis on
s'est amélioré beaucoup comme témoin au
terme de deux capables d'animer un
podcast lors des conversations comme ça
je voulais qu'on reçoive gabriel en fait
parce qu'il ya un podcast qui en
régissent dans le studio sf qui
s'appelle le comité des idées
dangereuses dans lequel il discute à
chaque semaine d'une idée dangereuse
plus ou moins mais surtout selon qui en
fait puis je voulais qu'on voulait en
fait quelques podcasts soit pas
nécessairement partisans
on voulait pas que gabriel arrive ici en
parlant québec solidaire de placer ses
idées politiques mais on voulait
discuter avec lui de plusieurs idées
suite aux crises que ce soit économique
ou sociale ou sanitaire en fait d'un des
derniers mois on voulait voir comment
gabriel voyait sur comment voyez le
futur pour le québec quels seraient les
avenues possibles
on ne parle évidemment de l'aco vide on
a parlé de la relance de l'économie on a
parlé de la crise environnementale on a
parlé du mouvement black light
demandeurs on a touché vraiment
plusieurs sujets et avril que quelqu'un
qui est capable de faire un sommaire
très efficace de ces idées toutes les
questions qu'on lui posait cette
question apparemment cnep apparemment
mais de toute évidence auquel il avait
déjà réfléchi longuement puis est
capable de transmettre on dit de façon
très efficace donc que vous soyez
d'accord ou non avec les idées
dangereuses qu'on a partagé durant le
podcast partagez-la participer pardon à
la discussion dans les commentaires like
et nos pros de castres puis une autre
affaire aussi sur la page sur notre page
pétrole on a commencé à faire un segment
qu'on appelle avec encore moins de
filtres ou moins de filtre encore encore
moins de films encore moins de filtres
ou est-ce qu'on discute tout de suite
après le podcast d'un homme puis moi
avec nicole on discute à chaud des
conversations convient d'avoir fait que
si vous voulez avoir accès à ce contenu
excusez fleurs le lien pour être dans la
description du podcast trois pièces par
mois vous avez accès à toutes les encore
moins de filtres qui sont après les
shows qu'on enregistre ici
donc si je pense que j'ai déjà parlé
assez sans plus attendre
profitez de cette conversation le puits
puis bon podcast
[Musique]
gab
merci beaucoup d'être leur salut tu as
été notre deuxième invité de toute
l'histoire du bagas je savais pas qu'il
a on est deux ans plus tard on approche
notre 100e épisode puis et puis je pense
que le monde a changé grandement les
deux dernières années plus que de mon
vécu au complet j'ai l'impression oui
puis dans les trois derniers mois il a
changé
voilà ce qui avait changé dans l'année
une milliard en ressort que ça bouge
plus j'ai l'impression que c'est pas
fini le seuil j'ai l'impression que
notamment de sujets qu'on pourrait
parler en ce moment aujourd'hui quelque
chose qui se portent au québec
politiquement puis socialement puis dans
le monde aussi
j'ai vraiment l'impression que des
soulèvements sociale des catastrophes
naturelles des pandémies des tout ce qui
crée des changements profonds ça va
devenir monnaie de plus en plus courant
ben je savais qu là avec la crise
climatique tu es qui sera pas aussi
subite va pas nouveau il va pas encore
une fois une conférence de presse où le
premier ministre dire ça commence on
ferme tout mais le sentiment de perdre
le contrôle sur les éléments sur ce qui
nous entoure le sentiment ce soir d'été
branly pesek vulnérables je pensais
beaucoup c'est le sentiment qu'on a eus
individuellement puis collectivement
dans grosso modo les trois derniers mois
du sentiment là je pense qu'il faut s'y
habituer parce que c'est un vague de
plus en plus fréquent de se sentir comme
ça à la merci de circonstance qui nous
échappe complètement
c'est dur d'imaginer à quoi le monde va
rassembler dans 50 ans s'entend vraiment
ça change tellement rapidement puis j'ai
l'impression qu'on peut tellement autant
prendre un virage bonté y presque
utopique qu autant qu'on peut prendre un
virage dans 50 ans ça soit le compliquer
à août
je suis regardons ce qui se passe aux
etats unis tu es là boys sont à cette
croisée des chemins en ce moment bien
une intensité de beaucoup
supérieure à celle que ça ici ce choix
la maison qui sont devant devant sauter
avec d'un côté une vision du monde
incarné par 30 et ultra violente de
trois assists le trop capitaliste et je
sais que cette visite vise exactement
c'est de l'eau un mouvement social
l'assembleur qu'on n'a pas vue depuis en
fait le mouvement des droits civiques
pendant les années 60 70 avec des
manifestations énorme très grande
majorité pacifiques des gens qui veulent
transformer la société il ya vraiment
une intersection historique ici c'est ça
existe aussi c'est aussi intense
nous soutenons le voit c'est le genre de
choix qu'on va avoir à faire dans les
prochaines années
puis le 3 mois qu'on vient de passer en
terme d'intensité social d'intensité
politique pour le meilleur et pour le
pire c'est le genre de situations dans
lesquelles je pense on va se retrouver
de plus en plus faut s'y habituer les
derniers les derniers mois ont vraiment
mis l'emphase sur j'ai l'impression un
système brisé autant par la crise blake
au vide puis tout ce que cela implique
et d'un point de vue de remettre en
question l'économie à tout prix puis ce
qui se passe en ce moment avec le
mouvement le mouvement pour black light
vendeur ou est-ce que l'on remet en
question des fondamentaux de la société
comme les forces policières par exemple
j'ai l'impression que ça a vraiment mis
l'enfant sur le fait que le système
comme on le connaît doit changer
absolument tout
jeu complètement d'accord avec toi que
j'ai l'impression que dans les trois
derniers mois il ya plusieurs des élèves
des fondations comme se disait de notre
société qui qui sont qui sont ébranlées
à part ça il faut quand même être
réaliste moi je fais pas partie des gens
qui pensent que parce qu'une crise comme
ça survient nécessairement après les
choses changer les choses peuvent aussi
resté exactement que de ce fait peuvent
aussi s'empirer ça va dépendre de ce que
nous le monde ont décidé de faire de ce
que les citoyennes et citoyens
ordinaires ont décidé de prendre comme
décision ce que les gens ont décidé de
s'impliquer de se réapproprier ces
enjeux-là de se réapproprier la
politique au sens général dont elle se
fait pas juste dans les partis qui fait
de plaine manière où est-ce qu'ils vont
laisser passer ce moment là puis dans
deux ans on va se dire oui finalement
les russes est un homme crise l'appui on
est dans le même québec dans le même
quart d'heure dans dans le même monde
nous sommes en jeu ne sais pas mais oui
ça tu auger centimes aussi toutes ces
remises en question loeb tout les toutes
les certitudes qui ont été ébranlés
d'abord par la pandémie où on s'est
rendu compte que en fait l'économie
pouvait s'arrêter qui avait d'autres
choses qui prenait plus d'importance que
ça ensuite presque coup sur coup les
normes débat autour de blacklight marula
c'est sur les injustices interne à la
société conchos questionnent de plus en
plus on avance très rapidement la sem a
totalisé dans le tour quatre mois je
t'avais dit
le spvm voir reconnaître que du racisme
système de malades sans jamais dire ça
tu es fou je crois que l'épisode va être
diffusée mais il ya eu quelques sorties
d'argent j'aurais pas mis d'argent
là-dessus que la scala 4 créer un
communiqué quel premier ministre la
semaine passée disent y'en a pas de
racisme systémique qu'une semaine plus
tard il y eut forcé est pratiquement à
causer l'opinion populaire des créer un
comité contre le racisme c'est que
l'opinion change excessivement
rapidement piqué le pouvoir
peuple vraiment un pouvoir immense c'est
dans ces moments là qu'on le voit si les
choses peuvent changer rapidement
mais ça arrive pas tout seul ça tombe
pas du ciel ces changements sociologue
pourquoi est-ce que ça a presque en
trois semaines dans l'impression d'avoir
fait plus de chemin sur la question du
racisme quand cinq ans c'est parce qu'il
ya du monde 1 rue quoi 15000 personnes
dans les rues de morale à au moins deux
reprises n'a eu que ce monsieur 15000
personnes 1 rue notre clé ville de tous
les véhicules notre côté d'antalis
c'est pour ça que les choses changent
c'est parce que le monde ammann et qui
qu'est-ce qu'ils déclenchent ça si
quelqu'un connaissait cette science là
pour déclencher soi mais il ya des
moments comme ça dans l'histoire il ya
des circonstances des événements pilote
à part les choses transforme très
rapidement possiblement qu'il faut si
john floyd s'est effectuée dans un
contexte où est ce qu'il y avait par
exemple la nba où est ce qu'il y avait
des distractions est ce que les gens
travailler 40 heures par semaine ou
est-ce que les gens probablement que sar
est passé beaucoup plus comme toutes les
autres fois que c'est arrivé avant c'est
une bonne question c'est quand c'est
comme un timing voit ce que les gens
avaient gens ont eu le temps de
s'arrêter
littéralement cette question parce qu'il
y avait rien dedans à fond puis ou si je
pense que tu es arrivé tout le temps
avance et toujours arriver sauf que le
sait de plus en plus difficile de pas le
voir parce que c'est toujours filmé
depuis enterré sur les réseaux sociaux
pis une coupe des vidéos qui sont sortis
après noël qui avait été filmé ses
décaissements des viols dans la
politique on voit puis que la vidéo dure
12 minutes une fille qui se fout y est
c'est pas bête que tu dis sur le fait
que les circonstances où tout le monde
était un peu déjà sur le qui-vive
déstabiliser dans son quotidien
personne n'était dans le
au boulot dodo déséquilibré dans sa vie
quotidienne par les circonstances de la
pandémie
c'est pas bête comme idée que est-ce que
ça a pu jouer dans le fait que les gens
ont réagi aussi fort parce que yi
s'apprêtait à un autre vidéo ça papillon
pas pu passer à autre chose dans la tête
de nouvelles piles image est juste qu'il
faut qu'un crawford pitié face à petit
symbole en image qui vient frapper
l'imaginaire des gens qui viennent
le ca le rentre-dedans d'un trip qui
laisse a fait la différence mais il ya
un aspect très ils commerçaient de
coïncidences là dedans c'est pour ce
geste pas une science qu'est ce qui fait
qu'un mouvement citoyen mouvement social
ordre coup t'es pas au printemps arabe
par exemple par 2011 où ce jeune homme
dans un pays dont on parle presque
jamais qui décident de s'immoler par le
feu
et ce geste là finalement déclenché des
révolutions politiques dans plusieurs
pays arabes
qu'est ce qui fait que c'est est ce ce
geste là cette année la même chose avec
le décès de georges floride pourquoi
c'est ce décès là parce que celui d'eric
corner puis lui parce qu'il ya un
symbole parce qu'il ya un contexte est
bon la présidence de trump aussi aussi
loin contribuer à augmenter les tensions
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme une espèce de
formule magique qui se met en place et
lol et le mouvement pas puis on monte
pas fini de voir les transformations
sociales qui vont être issu de ce
mouvement le yacht de raison de les
traiter le premier mis sur pied un
comité de travail mais on peut critiquer
sa composition son mentor je peux rien
je pourrais en parler longtemps mais
quand même ce gouvernement se promener
ce n'aurait jamais fait ça
jamais jamais en sentant savait pas été
du mouvement social gens qui y vont fait
ils vont toujours préféré par avoir des
recommandations se mettre en place des
mesures resteront parlement sont
probablement pas parfaite probablement
possède comme boire
j'aurais mis sur pied mais ils vont
quand même qu'ils vont finir par faire
quelque chose quand même ça c'est le
crédit ya 300 % aux gens qui se sont
mobilisés exact c'est ce mois c'est ce
qui me fait le plus qui a pas de la
danse et à quel point le pouvoir
le peuple du pouvoir comme je l'aï dit
tantôt que ça l'est vraiment un effet
concret et rapide un pic à tisser ici
réellement comment un parti d'opposition
le finalement le peuple a fait un
brillant encore beaucoup plus influents
le même nous mettons ben moi je t'aurais
partis d'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale nous l'ont notre pouvoir d'
influence sur le gouvernement y est
directement proportionnel à ce qui se
passe dans société à ce qui se passe
dans rue c'est lui le fameux comité le
jeu ils ont été créés d'ailleurs suite à
une motion que québec solidaire a déposé
c'est nous qui avons déposé une motion à
l'assemblée pour dire on veut un plan de
lutte au racisme et la discrimination
par près mines et sadio québec jean
faire un truc créé un comité pour mettre
sur pied ce plan de lutte mais nous
cette motion là qu'on dépose comme
partie de position là aucune chance de
passer en temps normal et pas ce jour là
parce que trois jours à vailhauquès
belle personne d'ailleurs à montréal
tous les médias parlent de sort il ya
des personnalités publiques des
minorités visibles à tous les jours dans
les médias pour dire ça m'est arrivé ça
existe c'est un problème qui nous ne
pouvoir des fluence le cas font ces jeux
sont ricochet de ce que le monde fonce
et qui moi je le vis comme personne qui
fait de la politique dans l'opposition
tout le temps là un enjeu on a du
pouvoir puis on a une influence
gouvernement seulement si on élire les
noms porte quelque chose d'autre qui se
passe dans société sinon la plupart de
nos propositions puis de nos gestes sont
cependant les différences je pense qu'un
haut rhin justement je pense que les
citoyens s'en rendre compte de ses
pouvoirs le de cette force le pis on le
sent qu'il ya un intérêt piquant comme
un espèce dvi ou aux questions sociales
par les politiques ses pieds on avait
parlé justement qu'elle était venue de
deux ans que c'est moi mettons 2012
avait été un jardin d'éveil justement à
ces questions le social par la politique
pileux on sent un même genre sur un
autre contre nos sujets bonsoir même
genre d'affairé
encore une fois oui pis pour ça qu'il
faut faire attention quand quand un
mouvement comme celui qu'on vit
actuellement finit par s'estomper parce
que ça va savoir est tombé c'est sûr et
certain ça arrive de job c'est normal
souvent on est très prompt très rapide
est renvoyé au finalement ça rien donné
sa peau changement
moi ce que je ramène tout le tapis je
pense que lieu deux ans vous avez fait
mais c'est ce qui vient après des années
plus tôt comme ça alors qu'est le monde
que ce mouvement-là réveillé après lyon
fait ceci selon ion parti tel projet
lyon sont engagés dans un parti dans un
syndicaux dans un groupe qui ont fait un
pacte qui sont faites on a fait mieux
qu'un livre pisser c'est ça l'héritage
souvent de ces mouvements là c'est tous
les gens que ça met en action pics
highgate puis je pense que je du moins
j'ose espérer c'est une zone mais ton
avec la plate forme qu'on a du studio on
a activement réfléchir à comment on peut
s'impliquer c'est à notre façon puis
j'ai l'impression que ça l'a fait ça
pour beaucoup de monde
puis j'ose espérer que ça va rester dit
que c'était pas un espèces provoquent
vraiment qui en a qui ont embarqué dans
le bernois gun parce qu'à un certain
moment c'était peut-être ndi sur
instagram mais c'est inévitable s'en
fout un pull
mais après ça c'est qu'ils veulent
vraiment capable de faire un réel
changement sa façon ses pieds je pense
avoir récité j'ose croire mais ça mais
le fait à moi aussi tout mon temps comme
député la gg ugg une équipe on a dur du
taf loi à l'assemblée mais aussi dans
nos circonscriptions pillon lui la
réflexion dans les dernières semaines on
l'avait déjà mais encore plus
intensément que les biens de semaine bon
notre staff le hiatus représentatif du
québec de 2020 puis on a beau être on
essaie toujours d'être les meilleurs les
plus vertueux à québec solidaire mais
crée on s'est rendu compte que n'est pas
parfaite en search maps puis on s'est
donné des objectifs pour que dans nos
prochaines en embauchant on corrige tous
ces facteurs nous qui se font de la
politique à temps plein le 10 à nous
c'est une prise de conscience qui on
change de comportement fait que si ça le
fait pour nous je pense que tu as bien
raison de dire que ça le fait pas ben du
monde sait pour qui c'est encore plus
nouveau qui se disait que ouais
je réalise ce si je réalise cela parce
que un mouvement de cette ampleur l'os
c'est ce que ça fait ça ébranle l'egypte
les gens se mettent à se poser des
questions tu parlais tantôt de la
gouvernance de trump ainsi une des
choses qui dans tout ça m'a frappé le
plus c'est à quel point il ya une
division claire dans le monde
puis puis les états unis est un
microcosme de seul sait c'est trop
évident et y envoyer des vidéos de
suprémaciste blanc avec des pancartes
marquées votre forum puis il ya eu une
manifestation qui passe devant chez eux
en respect le titille chante un mot il
chante une chanson de cépie les blancs
les genres de red neck fait poster où il
y en a un qui joue sur le coup de
l'autre qui il envoie chier en partant
dans la rue puis comme j'ai juste cette
image là est tellement frappante de la
police qui sépare mais la police prenne
pas position ils font juste roulé puis
empêché qu'il ya des débordements mais
c'est une violence folle et que c'est
encore pire que de quelques une bataille
assez à mains nues tpiy pendant ce temps
l'autre tel président kiki truite
déniaise reid qui qui entretient ce
climat la formule sur le feu c'est un
fait capoter de voir ce set
ces divisions lois existent partout mais
je pense pas qu'elles ont la même
intensité partout tu es ici au québec le
sans vouloir être faire de l'angélisme
non je pense au débaut public encore
comparativement aux états unis
relativement santé d'elijah on est
encore capable au québec contre je
laisse pas plus je le parle de discuter
de ces affaires là sans tomber la
majorité du temps dans des délires comme
ça aux états unis il faut quand même
remettre ce rappel c'est une société qui
depuis les années 90 au moins est
incapable de
q tu es l'espace public là aux états
unis le monde médiatique là qui est
censé être l'endroit où dans une société
démocratique on échange des idées on
n'est pas d'accord mais on argumente on
se change le monde etc au dessus des
nuages
quel bord qu'est ce que je lis bon cette
délibération c'est peut-être
conversation collective nos fonds aux
états unis elle est complètement déréglé
malades délirante depuis au moins 30 ans
c'est fox news l'a d'ailleurs une super
série là dessus qui s'appelle un monde
auquel le titre c'est une série dédiée
au sol assure la création de fox news
qui l'empiré médiatique de la droite
droite de la droite américaine
le dommage qu'on fait ces médiums à la
conversation collective aux états unis
c'est délirant
csx et incompréhensibles pour nous des
fous exactement quebecor c'est pas la
même ligue
j'étais foxnews la cndc une des chaînes
les plus aiguë aux états unis et 24
heures sur 24
peu importe où tu es aux états unis tu
peut l'ouvrir et tenant un discours
réactionnaire c'est comme une machine
distributrice jeudi à temps plein qui
alimente bien sûr chrome qui a qui
alimente le spray massis meublant les
théories du complot semmering
ici ça existe un fossé à quel point on
est chanceux d'un certain point de vue
des ctt d'avoir été préservé un de ce
dérapage totalement états unis ces
essais les gens sont plus capables de se
parler
les américains ne discute plus entre eux
une société complètement déchiré j'ai
tendance à croire qu'on n'est pas encore
rendue au québec une bonne chose même si
mes tantes et il ya quand même
beaucoup d espace à un certain discours
un certain discours de la droite assez
assez problématique je la gère ça existe
et ça existe je pense qu'il a plus
petite échelle
on le vit un peu j'ai l'impression s'est
il par exemple vous ouvrez les pages de
certains journaux vous allez trouver des
articles qui dit il ya du racisme anti
blanc blanc soit aux attaques
ça existe vous êtes capable dans la
dernière année de trouver quelques
textes non des médiums entre 5,6 texte
de jean la thune 0 5 ou 6 2 trous juin
d'accord c'est pôle marine
c'est pas la même ligue 1 ou pillées ou
encore surtout au québec les gens les
gens il ya encore comment dire du
chevauchement entre les différentes
bulles sociale les grossistes l'arrêt
complet comme si c'est pareil tous deux
nient cdc des religions dans le monde
qui comptent foxnews tellement king de
cnn
c'est des religions puis ça ne se
parlent pas pile les on écoute pas les
autres ils se croisent jamais dans le
quotidien des bleus autoroutes et des
gens qui se voient pas qu'ils se parlent
pas qu'ils vivent dans des pays
différents côte à côte
je pense pas qu'on ait rendu au québec à
un niveau de fracture sociale aussi
grave
mais ce que serait ce que le nook est
tout à fait mais j'ai encore l'optimisme
le diront puis moi je le vois tu m'aimes
dans la culture politique même avec mes
adversaires politiques au parlement où
on est allé plus loin
quand même encore capables de se parler
puis on n'est pas sur des planètes
différentes
puis après ça même si l'elysée s'est
même si les injustices ou même ses
tracts sur le haut même si et des
problèmes qui sont plus graves plus
grands 2 mi temps 2 0
si un peu d'action qui te reposer cité
ça sera comme dans un sens plus rien à
dire c'est pas parce qu'ils ont des
problèmes sont par ailleurs quand pas
ici c'est de faire mieux qu'une seconde
de ce pouvoir de contrôle sur ce qui se
passe ici ce qui en fait est que les
états unis je pense doivent nous servir
d'avertissement c'est l'inconscient
c'est là qu'on s'en va
si on fait rien si on laisse les
personnes qui ont un disque aux deux
divisions
prendre le haut du pavé sont là répond
pas si on mène pas la bataille des idées
comptent ces gens là il ya un risque
c'est vers là qu'on s'en aille
enfin que les états unis ils sont une
comparaison intéressante pour ça pour
nous dire pour nous servir
d'avertissement mais on n'est pas encore
là heureusement puis admettre aux
conjoints petit peu à ton podcast le
comité n'est dangereuse ces quads et
c'est quoi des pistes selon toi de
solutions à appelons ceux appelons ce
même si non ça faut faire référence à
autre chose l'espèce de problématiques
du discours médiatique
comment est-ce qu'on parvient à régler
ça ou a tempéré sûr parce que j'ai
l'impression que le une spirale un peu
hors de contrôle qui est alimenté par le
clic bay qui est alimenté par des textes
sans nuances qui est alimenté par du
mauvais journalisme ou double est-ce que
ça s'appelle du journalisme c'est des
pignons des fenêtres journal d'opinion
violée comment est ce qu'on fait pour
éviter tomber dans cette spirale
quand je demande à la crise des médias
ou est-ce que ya plus d'argent
ou est-ce que la seule chose qui ramène
ton argent c'est les clics sur ces faits
mettons qu'on a une idée dangereuse
comment on sort souvent dans justement
créé mon podcast pour essayer de trouver
la solution première tôle froissée
décide comprendre ses couettes c'est
quoi le problème qui vient d'où by la
montée appelons ceux du sensationnalisme
ou juste même la montée de l'opinion
dans les médias toujours pas mal sourire
toujours eu de l'opinion dans les mythos
a toujours existé ça qu'on assiste
depuis quelques décennies c'est la
proportion d'opinions s'agrandit
s'agrandit s'agrandissent a grandi et
c'est lié à la dynamique l'aude clic
bête ou de sensationnalisme puis
pourquoi c'est c'est directement lié à
la crise des médias c'est parce que les
médias sont plus capables de faire de
l'argent avec du journalisme qui se
tourne vers l'opinion parce que c'est
une des dernières afin qu'ils leur
permettent fable
de générer des revenus pourquoi parce
que l'heureux leurs sources de revenus
traditionnels histoire et la publicité a
été complètement cannibalisé par les
géants du web google amazon facebook ce
qu'on appelle soit les légats farc dont
cette source de revenus historiques
n'existant plus la publicité ce qui fait
ce que ce qui génère du revenu c'est le
clic sur le web
et qu est ce qu est le tout devient
dépendant de ce trafic l'appui comment
tu vas le chercher le trafic pas avec un
article qui te prend trop au mois et
créé parce que tu payes un journaliste
dans cas puisqu'il prend alors à
l'espace le rapport coût bénéfice est
passé bon qu'est ce qui te fait qu'est
ce qui maximise son profit c'est un
article écrit très rapidement par
quelqu'un que tu paye souvent au cash
est pas que tu plonges journaliste
salarié istres crâne car à qui tu donne
un cachet qui te sort 1 250 400 mots
avec une opinion incendiaires peu
documenté que le monde vont partager
parce qu'ils sont pour parce qu'ils sont
cons qui le tu vois tu veux tu vas
chercher du trafic comme celui ci
beaucoup plus rentables comme modèle que
modèle où tu vas de la publicité pendant
des mois pendant des journalistes
feuillade aussi les mots les maisons ont
plus les moyens de face donc qui ont
selon lui on retrouve en solutionnera
pas le problème de la démagogie de
l'opinion délirante puis du pilat des
informations sans régler le problème
comment on fait en sorte que les médias
qui sont des institutions est
essentielle dans notre société ait les
moyens de faire leur travail
convenablement pour moi c'est
directement direct une des pistes de
solution c'est de venir en aide
financièrement massivement ces médias
lors avec des conditions par contre pas
de question que gouvernement allemand
mais d'abord que le gouvernement donne
de l'argent et que cet argent là s'en
aille pour faire de la chronique ou
ou ou de l'opinion faut que l'argent
lassana et pour financer des
journalistes dans des salles de
nouvelles qui vont donner de
l'information de qualité au monde
l'information fiable pilotera face avec
des balises en effet pour pas que cet
appui financier la vienne avec un genre
de contrôle ou de la condition n'a pas
des gouvernements mais honnêtement en ce
moment notre problème principal c'est
pas que les gouvernements veulent
s'ingérer dans le contenu en ce moment
ce qui s'ingèrent dans le contenu c'est
les entreprises privées qui financent
sur reportage puis finances des
publireportages pour toutes sortes de
cahiers spéciaux plus de patente et
l'ingérence dans le contenu en ce moment
là il y en a mais à vient pas dans un
gouvernement à vis du privé fac pour moi
une des pistes de solution c'est ça et
donner aux médias les moyens de faire
leur job parce que faire sortir de
l'information de qualité selon ça coûte
cher selon ça coûte cher c'est beaucoup
trop leur donner les moyens de le
frapper
moi je pense que son investissement sur
la qualité de notre débat collectif
fascinant regardons états unis le tcc
lock on s'en va si si on ne fait rien
comme tu disais tu es si ces textes
d'opinion le titre des gens qui qui vont
prendre un texte par jour le temps quel
point elle en mai qu'elle prête à
rechercher ou plus à quel point tu
cherches et approfondie à quel point tu
réfléchiras situation a tout son temps
de réflexion
c'est impossible c'est d'avoir une
opinion forme est clair sur autant de
sujets à chaque jour est possible les
hausses à une place dans le monde
médiatique l'analyse la chronique
l'opinion ça a toujours existé mais ça
ça fait partie de je pense une offre
médiatique globale ou non peuvent ça
peut les aider à se faire une idée à se
forger une opinion c'est super sain mais
dans une certaine proportion puis d'une
certaine manière c'est clairement si
j'ai fait de mon ma maîtrise sur le
nouveau journalisme le petit c c'était
ce qui m'intéressait le plus dans le
concept du nouveau journalisme c'est de
prendre tellement de temps pour nuancer
un sujet tellement de ressources puis
d'investiguer tellement pitt de juste
m'imaginer
que tu restes hansen 40 ans qui
travaillait dans plusieurs journaux aux
états unis où est ce qu il était dans sa
chambre d'hôtel à à travailler sur son
truc dit son espoir appelé pizza et
après est ce que tu te quelque chose
pour moi je voulais juste dire non ça
sera pas au niveau que je veux que ce
soit ce sera pas là la meilleure
information possible c'est d'imaginer ce
monde là on dirait que ça ça remet
vraiment perspective qui est ce que tu
peux lire maintenant sur un c log si ça
existe encore il ya encore d'excellents
de l'excellent journalisme qui ce fils
d'un faux pas c'est toujours de j'aime
quand j'essaie dé jamais tomber dans la
rhétorique pas dans le bon vieux temps
depuis l'âge d'or chaque époque a ses
problèmes pilleurs et pour des grues et
des gaines retour 90 lutté mais est donc
ce que je dis ça existe encore sorti
encore des gens qui dédient en eau moins
qu'avant ils ont moins de moyens
qu'avant mais ça existe encore ça qu'on
part pas de rien que du monde pour moi
j'ai été dans le milieu des médias
pendant quelques années encore beaucoup
de gens qui croient cet idéal qui essaie
de s'en rapprocher le plus possible afin
que moi je refuse d'être complètement
pessimiste de dire aux à l'époque
c'était magnifique
aujourd'hui c'est la catastrophe et il
ya des gros défis des gros problème
aujourd'hui
mais il ya du monde qui sont prêtes à
mener cette bataille y compris à
l'intérieur des organisations
médiatiques
il faut donner de l'argent selon nos
informations la à la taille des groupes
médiatiques landais et à vous maintenant
de rené le label est une bonne manière
si on cherche un petit peu la
conversation vers
ballack au vide qu'est ce que ça l'a
amené dans climat actuel dans le monde
on aurait le sommet j'ai envie de lancer
la discussion avec le avec l'idée de
consommer local qui est devenu vraiment
que pris une ampleur énorme pendant le
haka vite puis ou où est ce que je veux
amener ça c'est peut-être peut-être que
je suis pessimiste à l'idée de penser
que ça va continuer parce que on attend
quelqu'un on va sortir la coved soir la
chance d'acheter un t-shirt à dix pièces
ou un tee shirt du québec à 25
ça se peut que les convictions prennent
le bord rapidement
oui exactement que là la tendance du
consommer local pendant la pandémie
s'effrite un petit moins exact puis
alors qu'à alors que techniquement cette
idée là de consommer local peut garder
ses six est idéal
pepy on va se dire c'est une idée qui si
elle y pose juste une mode qui si elle
est poussé assez loin c'est une idée qui
est révolutionnaire parce que vous c'est
quoi la mentalité avec laquelle on a
développé notre système économique
depuis les années 90
mettons 30 à la mentalité complètement
inverse
c'est la logique de la délocalisation
c'est à dire on va regarder dans notre
économie au québec chaque affaire chacun
paul fischer bien sûr ça commence et
beaucoup par les vêtements mais
évidemment l'électro et la grande
majorité des biens de consommation la
fête 30 ans québec convoqué tout ce
qu'on peut produire ailleurs moins cher
on va le produire ailleurs montchamp
puis on va garder ici jusqu'à ce qu'il
faut absolument faire ici ou les deux ou
trois créneaux d'excellence où l'on va
se spécialiser tout notre modèle
économique au québec on veut le
développer autour de 2,3 à faire vos
puis on les connaît l'aéronautique par
exemple
l'intelligence artificielle on va cibler
deux trois domaines d'excellence où on
est bon et dans les fêtes prenant tout
le reste on voyait on va envoyer ça
ailleurs pourquoi parce que les droits
des travailleurs travailleuses sont par
contre je n'aime pas ça coûte moins cher
les réglementations environnementales
sont moins exigeants enfin qu' on serait
moins chier on peut pas lui plus ça
coûte donc ça coûte moins cher à
produire et donc droit de travail -
moins exigeants règles environnementales
moins exigeantes
donc on voit qu'il ya pas de vendre
moins cher c'est son lancer le logiciel
à partir duquel on a développé
l'économie depuis 30 ans et sortir de ça
pour des raisons écologiques pour des
raisons sociales
on va relocaliser l'économie
c'est ça sert un potentiel de vraiment
transformer notre société si ça casse
pas juste une mode 6 à 6 à ce même si
quiconque fait des choix politiques en
disant non un instant là on va sortir
l'argent puis on va relocaliser notre
économie sas a le potentiel d'être
quelque chose comme une vraie
transformation du québec
est-ce que ça va arriver quand on verra
si c'est le transporteur commis des
emails juste sur la narration ok on a
des lectrices damas des tirs ont fait
des serres au québec fournit
d'électricité pas cher on fait des
serres partout on augmente notre
autosuffisance alimentaire les
médicaments l'orne et anelka drogba
claquant des doigts peut créer une
pandémie ne masque ou si un vaccin qui
voulaient bon ils vont vouloir les
pognon va manquer ok on investit ont
coproduit notre propre matériel médical
nos propres vaccins nos propres
médicaments
c'est ce soit vrai projet de société
pis ces pandémies là nous ouvre cette
possibilité leur plantant la porte au
moins de s'en aller par le brr ça me
fait capoter en tout cas tenir et les
raisons pour lesquelles tonnes
délocaliser justement toutes ces
industries lot et puis tu es au québec
qu'un accident en amérique du nord
général on 11 vente de t&d société juste
et égalitaire pittsburgh pour les doigts
les travailleurs puis pour avoir des
bonnes conditions pitt se mais qu'elle
sait pas sous nos yeux que ça arrive à
d'autres c'est pas grave ça qu'on fait
jusqu au tombeau pour avoir de bonnes
conditions mais on fait faire nos
affaires dans des endroits où est ce que
les conditions sont parfois
complètement et c'était l'objectif comme
une conséquence malencontreuse
c'était l'objectif de l'opération toute
cette vision de l'économie ne s'est basé
là dessus on veut que le monde consomme
il faut baisser le prix des des objets
de consommation le monde revendique des
meilleures conditions comment on règle
ce problème renvoyée face à ça a été la
solution s'adapter si on n'est pas du
tout une société éthique être garanti à
l'échelle mondiale le thé on profite de
ce mets ton cas moi je parle de
véganisme c'est souvent ce qui revient
et c'est à dire un jeu je comprends ce
que tu me dis par rapport au fait qu tu
si tu veux pas créer la souffrance mais
en même temps elle leur est même exemple
tchèque ton tee shirts et shake ton
t-shirt ou est-ce que tu l'as acheté il
vient de ou est acquitté crie la
souffrance n'est pas des animaux mais
probablement que 18 à des gens et il
promet que contribuer à sa puis
effectivement tout le monde censément il
sait ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut jamais
oublier c'est que ses poches le fait que
notre économie fonctionne comme ça c'est
paul seulement le résultat d'une
addition de choix individuel c'est pas
juste parce que le monde sont pas
corrects et c'est vraiment c'est le
programme économique les accords
économiques qu'on ne signé par exemple
les accords de libre échange
c'est écrit comme ça c'est l'objectif de
l'opération dont un autre exemple on
peut acheter un jeu dans l'assemblée
nationale au parlement je serai un débat
avec la milice de la santé sur les
médicaments et moi l'idée que je défends
dans ce débat là c'est qu'il faudrait
faire le plus possible nos médicaments
au québec puis on devrait en faire
publiquement parce que les compagnies
pharmaceutiques cd esti il nous arnaque
puis sa part le puits on est dans des
battles admin c'est l'ami de la santé
elle me dit ouah mais l'homme cela 12
bat vous oubliez que il ya certains des
ingrédients actifs d comme d un des
éléments base dans le fond des
médicaments que produire ça c'est juste
prix en fête à midi on les produit
seulement en inde et en chine
ouais ben c'est en ce moment comme ça on
pourrait le faire ici pm10 en en on peut
pas faire ça ici c'est beaucoup trop
polluants
[Rires]
aion donc vous attend très modèle et
remettent ça comme ça le poids comme
gênés ou honte aux traîtres et
transparent plus bas on le fait quand
parce que vous comprenez que la
pollution à la regarde pas à la fraude à
la loi
ça reste comme les gaz un fêtard et la
pile vous êtes en train de me dire il
faut surtout pas relocalisé ça parce que
ces polluants vous êtes donc en train de
me dire que c'est vraiment préférable de
polluer là bas parce que ça nous dérange
moins c'est une absurdité
mais mais c'est ma vision c'est ça qui
sait assumer comme ça l'évolution halo
et celle à québec qu'il a créée que la
barre est de dépasser une consommation
qui est la cause directe de la
production de cette pollution sauf que
c'est le para et c'est autant de temps à
y regarder qui polluent c'est une
stratégie aussi pour pouvoir dire voilà
on atteint nos cibles parce qu'on a
juste délocaliser pas juste la
production mais aussi la création des
sabres à venir sur la pandémie t on les
autres dans la pandémie le notre
vulnérabilité notre fragilité à l'égard
de l'extérieur le fait qu'on s'est mis à
manquer de certaines choses rue d'en
face on lui en pleine phase pis ça ouvre
une possibilité de doit être vraiment
changé la manière dont notre économie
fonctionne qui moi ça me ça me motive
- pis c'est une occasion que je pense
qu'il faut saisir est-ce qu'on vole
c'est ce qu'on va la saisir ce aussi pas
mais l'occasion et l'île aux pieds les
magnifiques
maintenant ça le fait une maîtrise en
pharmacie puis aux dames pour le
développement de médicaments je te
demande bien amère alors commencer un
nouveau bac après sa maîtrise pas ce
qu'elles se trouvaient pas de job et
puis moi naïvement je demandais pourquoi
t'as pas de job pour développer des
médicaments vendus parce que toutes les
compagnies se sont délocalisés en
mayenne parce que là-bas ipod
législation des réglementations sur les
tests qu'ils peuvent faire mais comment
peut on en voit sur la bord continue à
développer les médicaments parce
qu'enfin ils permettent de traiter sur
sur des singes à akron ouvert pis encore
listé ses fous pareils de brasser ce
cccc la masse et pis c'est souvent ce
que j'appelle un logiciel parce que
c'est ce logiciel de développement
économique
il est une menace pour l'environnement
il est une menace pour les droits
sociaux y est insoutenable
écologiquement c'est juste impossible de
continuer comme ça transforme et ça
c'est s'attaquer au camp mais s'attaquer
à quelque chose qui fondamentale
économie si ça se fera pas sans
opposition exactement
il va falloir de la mobilisation seule l
autre chose on a reçu et mais le roi ou
pas de casse puis il ya dit quelque
chose d'idiot on est on est tellement
proche de 2 à france on est proche d'une
utopie puis on est proche une dystopie
comble puis je pense que avec la
situation actuelle où est-ce que tout
arrêté puis qu'on a on a l'occasion de
repartir on dirait que moi ce texte m
c'est un peu ce qui me rendait optimiste
dans la situation même si concrètement
au détour des sites et place des poches
c'était difficile pour tout le monde
puis on dirait que c'est l'idée de me
dire une occasion de faire un reset et
sur la sur la cassette de commencer puis
toile relançons ce puis j'ai envie de
discuter avec toi comment on pourrait
encore une fois en mode idée dangereuse
comment on pourrait relancer ce mieux
exact puis dernièrement évidemment il ya
eu la loi 71 sél espèce de débile
et complètement une scène pis c'est un
bon qualifier c'est toujours une part
les as-tu fait trois ans que pour
parlement puis j'en ai vu des lois un
mauvaise mais le fantasme et moules mais
un truc comme cela c'était vraiment le
truc le lapi raphaël revue au parlement
trois ans qui est de loin le c'était
vraiment broche à foin tout croche
j'ai jamais vu un projet de loi aussi
proche probant que ça c'était vraiment
bon en tout cas j'ai l'épaule et au
complexe ça me semble aberrant mais
admettons
c'est moi j'ai fait un petit peu de
business leur dans ma vie puis je sais
que quand tu veux on passe une vite tout
écrit une phrase quelques corps dans un
institut gros document phi phi je pense
qu'on fait c'est istres qui fait la
vidéo est ce que tu soulignes injuste
trois articles problématique
on a parlé yard sait que c'est en 2,1
2,1 espèce de point qui va tout changer
mais avant mettons qu'on démontre
complètement ses sbires liste écolo
objectif c'est la pertinence de cervélo
pis pour ceux qui existent je te
reprocher loi bien compliqué si
j'essayais de trouver des manières de
l'expliquer parce que moi un truc jugé
cette phase avec mon podcast mais pas
seulement c'est vulgariser ça prendra
fin compliquée et ses 35 pour le monde
qui font pas de la politique tous les
jours c'est la grande majorité des gens
pis la métaphore la meilleure métaphore
que j'ai trouvé pour expliquer c'était
quoi staff halles c'est une petite
histoire c'est l'histoire suivant le ton
vous êtes co vous savez j'étais cool on
va là vous allez la banque mondiale est
de décoller c'est comme si l'on entre
vous disais à eux je vais aller faire
l'épicerie prête moi mais le pias
l'autre est bon mais le ps c'est
beaucoup et que c'est un peu c'est un
peu c'est beaucoup quand je vois juste à
acheter
du lait et des oeufs ben là pourquoi tu
as besoin de mille pièces non t'inquiète
pas je veux donner le change mais je
veux bien qu'ils me donnent le change
c'est juste pas besoin de mille piastres
pourquoi je te prêterait me dise non
mais c'est juste pour être sûr que j'en
manque pas puis je vais te donner le
change
est ce que le colloque raisonnable
prêterait 1000 dhs alors à son colloque
pour sow tout est figé mais delajoux
mais ce projet de loi le lui c'est
exactement ça ils nous ont dit on a
besoin de relancer l'économie et donc
d'investir rapidement l'argent dans
l'industrie de la construction puis pour
faire ça 2-3 délai qu'il faudrait
raccourcir ses délais leur sont écrits
dans des lois et qu'au lieu de nous dire
on va raccourcir ce délai la x dans
cette loi x ils nous ont dit de ne
pouvoir de suspendre la loi au complet
pis un conseil des ministres de la
réécrire le nous ne régit un peu comme
le colloque dans mon histoire mais le
sapad alors d'où exactement quels délais
vous voulez raccourcir pillon enverront
va jaser mais on vous donnera pas full
authority sur la loi puis la réponse
était comme dans mon histoire le
colloque qui répondent non mais vous
inquiétez pas on vaut pas tous capella
loi jeu
je veux bien que vous ne sentirez de
vous faire nos viandes dans une
démocratie la job d opposition puis des
citoyens et puis la société civile c'est
pas de faire confiance aveuglément
ça m'a demandé des garanties s'est
assurée que des contre pouvoirs que des
balises puisque si le gouvernement
demande on impose de pouvoir
on peut décider oui ou non son rideau ne
repose mountain rider rapport marge de
manoeuvre complète sous prétexte qu'ils
nous garantit qu'ils vont utiliser je
serais pour ça c'est comme si
gouvernement lui demandait de donner
nous 98 % de marge de manoeuvre mais
vous inquiétez pas on va les utiliser 10
pour ça mais ça marche pas comme ça
ce projet de loi là c'est pour ça qu'ils
étaient complètement délirant dans le
petit vidéo j'ai fait j'ai essayé de
l'expliquer en sortant de trois articles
c'est qu'ils nous disaient donnez-nous
autorités total de changer à peu près
toutes les lois mais vous inquiétez pas
aux lf repos mais il n'y a jamais un
député d'opposition dans un parlement de
l'histoire de toutes les parlements dit
qu'ils auraient signé te dis là c'est
juste nous demander d'arrêter de faire
le job
petit demander aux citoyens d'arrêter de
faire leur job c'est une bande et aux
groupes environnementaux à la ville
catherine général à toutes les actions
qu'on se donnait pour protéger les
citoyens se demander à tout ce monde-là
de signer un chèque en blanc puis
s'était mal fou dessus c'était
complètement délirant puis la réaction
de tout le monde de la gauche à la
droite a été dit ben non ça marche pas
c'est pour ça qu'on a réussi à le
bloquer mettons que j'essaie de faire la
vie quotidienne des grandes sagas de
l'été
j'écoutais les podcasts avec des lieux
car modillons qui reçut pauline marois
par zone pendant pandémie tipi a parlé
de nez ce qui s'était passé mais quand
hicks et pierre dick à ce moment là le
gouvernement avait pris des pouvoirs
extraordinaires
j'ai vraiment rapidement pour venir en
aide aux victimes à ce moment le temps
n'est pas passé par toutes les
démocraties qui des deux sous tipis la
lourdeur de tous ceux pour pouvoir
vraiment j'ai rapidement venir en haïti
est ce que c'est ce que serait pas
légitime dans des situations extrêmes
qu'un gouvernement prennent
temporairement des pouvoirs extrême tout
à fait mais le mot clic du ndi est
important temporairement qui pendant qu
une crise c'est dans toutes les dans
tous les pays ça existe en des lois qui
donne des pouvoirs exceptionnels dans
des situations exceptionnelles
ça permet par exemple ça permet au
gouvernement durant la pandémie de ne
pas respecter les conventions
collectives des travailleurs travaillant
dans le secteur de la santé ces sites au
sein du scot d'hibernate et passant si
tu t'es pas censé faire ceci mais l'oeil
une vie en jeu le gouvernement doit te
di bella le sein du copil contre travail
le plat convention collective d'une vie
en jeu on va tout ça c'est normal c'est
correct
par contre dans tous les pays du monde
ces dispositions là exceptionnels sont
toujours encadrées parce que tout le
monde voit ici qu'ailleurs c'est normal
que ça existe toujours un risque que les
gouvernements cellphone les pouvoirs
exceptionnels - c'est confortable un peu
comme du sud est peu près ce qu'on veut
tout les pouvoirs avec dans une
démocratie
la logique c'est toujours qu'on donne
soap temporairement mais qui a des
balisiers des garde-fous pour s'assurer
que les gouvernements ne prennent pas
trop
ou est ce parce que ça peut devenir le
phone pour un gouvernement depuis
l'opposition
on est bien on peut décider ce qu'on
veut bon et donc que ça ça existe une
chose qu'un gouvernement veulent
s'arroger ses pouvoirs là dans la
version initiale du projet doit rester
indéfiniment
oui c'est ça ça existe nulle prendre
longue c'est du délire
celle du jilin j'imagine que thil le
flou autour de toute cette loi là où
c'est un peu le reflet du flou dans
quelle association on est ici tu sais
pas combien de temps la pandémie va
encore durer le navire est on sait pas
exactement combien de temps qu'on va
être menée là dedans
si tu sais pas exactement quelles sont
les actions classiques je veux relancer
l'économie mais ton plat n'est pas
encore clair qu'est ce que tu vas faire
une loi flou qui fait quitteront
pourtant viré de bord sur un procès
quand je présume que stephen king king
derrière mettez mettront en ce moment là
la loi sur la santé publique qui est la
loi qui permet de déclencher l'état
d'urgence sanitaire a dit tu peux le
prolonger à coups de dijon puis on met
des limites feu à chaque jo prolongerait
mais sont obligés puis oui c'est un peu
grâce encore à zéro à chaque dix jours
de 10 rôle prolonge plus de justifier
pourquoi en nettement dans une
démocratie c'est normal que ce soit un
peu gosses à moi parce que c'est c'est
cela logique il faut que les pouvoirs
exceptionnels qu'il soit possible mais
faut pas qu'ils soient trop confortable
parce que l'objectif c'est que les
gouvernements sentent que c'est
justement temporaire et qui doivent
rendre des comptes
parce que sinon c'est arrivé dans
l'histoire des démocraties les moments
de crise peuvent
on peut perdre la démocratie dans un
moment c'est ce qu'il faut éviter pis tu
es tu l'as vu le temps des libéraux à
québec se donne à 100 par le barreau du
québec
bruce québec n'est pas l'extrême gauche
noté qu un touch maladie le vous venez
de d'enfreinte équilibre absolument
essentiel où les citoyens 80 je pense
que tous les citoyens sont prêtes à vous
donner des points que centenaire mais
pas n'importe comment qui pourra
sans surveillance mais c'est drôle que
tu faisais parce que j'ai eu un coup de
moins au début de la crise que navire eu
d'écouté c'est une clé fera pas ce
podcast le terme intéressant dans un
podcast avec une expertise sur ma
climatique expliqué prof en sciences
politiques dans le fond c'est parce que
la décence climatique est très politique
puis à 10 est dit nous en sciences
politiques
on est quasiment plus plus nerveux que
la santé publique la crise que le virus
parce qu'on le sait que dans les moments
de crise comme c'est la première chose
qui tombe c'est les démocraties prix les
pouvoirs publics vraiment qu'ils se
prennent des pouvoirs supplémentaires
depuis deux mois plus tard exactement ce
qu'est le but on a essayé de faire un
peu
à la véraison mais en même temps c'est
là où tu la profession que tu cites
avait raison le risque existait on a un
gouvernement québec qui a fait
exactement ce ils ont aussi et non
passer une petite vite au monde à l
allemande
ils nous aiment bay les sondages sont
bons ils créent essayons d'aller
chercher plus de pouvoirs et la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ça peut aujourd'hui
ça peut marcher
il ya eu beaucoup de gens de la
population s'est soulevée aussi j'avais
ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas vu
une mobilisation comme celle là sur le
web autour d'un projet de loi autour
d'un projet de loi le fou fou donc en
belgique se sont mis à nous écrire des
vidéos qu'on a faits qui ont eu ces 500
600 milles vue lundi on a senti que
encore il ya dans le peuple chez les
citoyens soyez en une cette vigilance
démocratique ou quand ils sentent qu'un
gouvernement exagère
il ya une réaction mais tu vois c'est
encore une fois le peuple qui réalise le
pouvoir qui est par exemple
l'entrevue que je parlais je me suis dit
quelque chose a emmené par rapport aux
changements climatiques
comparativement à la crue du chrono
virus comme de quoi en ce moment dans
l'histoire de l'humanité la crise
climatique se trouve à être comme si on
était en mars
la différence a dit bob marley l'a fait
rentrer les crises que le virus de la
grippe sur une thématique sauf que je
m'acclimate 6 ha ça se déroule en selon
moody's tandis que l'économie russe est
extrêmement rapidement
si on se replace dans l'histoire et
vidal l'évolution du changement
climatique des siècles ça faisait début
mars ses débuts mais mi mars mais ton
petit écran qui achètent un site de fans
30 ans c'est quand qu'on a commencé sa
rencontre
sauf que c'est quelque chose qui c'est
qui en fonde en slow motion qui m'a dit
ça va aussi être beaucoup plus long à
réparer et tandis qu'il entend les
actions qu'on ait des russes on prend
des actions qui suit on voit le résultat
1 200 confinement deux semaines plus
tard tu vois déjà la contagion des
décennies des siècles plus tard que nos
efforts vont commencer à voir si on fait
des efforts
c'est là que je voulais en venir puis
pour imaginer ses quelques heureux
navire est justement mi mars a frappé
pique les yeux des mesures drastiques le
pti du jamais vu de mon vivant ty comme
leur rester chez vous tout est fermé on
se barricade
puis j'ai l'impression que si on fait ce
travail là de se dire ah et le admettons
que la science nous dit que pour les
changements climatiques on se retrouve à
la mi mars du queyran au virus
mais c'est précisément le moment pour
éviter le pire
un qu'on prenne des décisions drastiques
pour que ça change la face que si on
attend plus tard que la situation soit
vraiment extrêmes comme le coût d'un
virus les têtes qu'on ressente l'urgence
si on se confine qu'on fait tout on
change nos actions il est trop tard si
c'est exact
exactement c'est une c'est une
comparaison merveilleuse parce que je
sais c'est exactement ça exactement ça
puis c'est la même logique que vous
venez de
dénommé c'est à dire plus on attend plus
va falloir poser des gestes extrêmes en
banque et donc deux choix c'est
commencer maintenant pouvoir faire pour
filer la métaphore du confinement plus
soft on attend plus longtemps puis
chypre où l hebdo fait pareil là c'est
juste que mon emploi pharma shop c'est
comme aux besoins comme comme dans
certains pays en europe
toi et puis en fait comme au québec où
on a été un petit peu plus lents à
prendre des premières mesures qu'il faut
lui à la mi mars
fermée plus vite ça nous a pas empêchés
d'avoir pas mal plus de mort fait
énormément plus de morts que dans les
cas plus de morts que tous les autres
provinces rien comme comme se rappeler
ça parce qu'on a pris trop taxé un
mauvais look c'est exister c'est une
comparaison absolument parfait c'est
plus on attend plus ça va être dur plus
on agit tôt plus on a une chance
d'aplatir la courbe climatique un examen
mettons comprend justement encore une
fois les idées dangereuses pour relancer
l'économie de façon verrais tu sais quoi
les pistes les plus soit prometteuse où
les avec le plus d'impact versus le coût
que cela aurait sur la vie des gens ben
déjà tout le pire que j'aie fait tantôt
sur la relocalisation de l'économie
c'est écologiquement une excellente idée
des fois aussi d'autres économistes vont
passer les circuits crolles isère
essayer quand la place aux produits où
on achète plus on consomme la distance
sur la sur la courbe cette fois ci ça
c'est ultra bon pour l'environnement
c'est autrement pour l'économie parce
qu'on crée des bonne job sur le
territoire proche du monde ce genre
ferai pas le peu de gelée fait tantôt
puis l'autre élément c'est les fameuses
investissements d'infrastructure noter
que qui était un peu le prétexte du
satané projet de loi 61 l'idée est ce ce
boulet de l'idée est bonne idée de dire
il faut investir dans l'économie parce
que quand il ya une récession comme en
ce moment que ce qui se passe c'est que
les entreprises privées
il ya règles y arrête on trie
ralentissent significativement leurs
investissements dans l'économie
taklha il ya un risque qu'on s'enfonce
qu'on s'enfonce conscience qu amour dans
ce contexte le rôle des gouvernements
c'est un peu disons le privé investit pu
nous autres on va investir quitte à
s'endetter un peu pour qu ex tard pour
redémarrer l'économie
cette idée là elle est bonne là dessus
on est d'accord peu près de la gauche la
droite le montant
c'est une bonne idée de face la question
c'est dans quoi tu mets ton argent
est-ce que tu troisième 15
infrastructures est-ce que tu le mets
dans le troisième ligne ça je pense
qu'ils ont une très mauvaise idée
ou est-ce que se mettent dans des
infrastructures comme du transport en
commun tram ou tramway la ligne rose à
montréal le rebel tramway à québec d'un
tramway à longueuil pas loin d'ici
le soc et c'est une occasion de
redémarrer l'économie de créer des
bandes d'hommes et de bec de diminuer
notre dépendance à la voiture de créer
des informations fit donc de résoudre la
crise climatique donc la pandémie elle
est tragique bien sûr mais elle ouvre
des opportunités l eau des opportunités
la question c'est ce qu'on va les
saisies rupo mais oui accélérée pourrait
le mettre le pied sur l'accélérateur à
fond sur les infrastructures vertes
c'est une excellente idée
le désaccord qu'on aime avec accepte pas
besoin de tout ce qu'a fait des lois
pour fasse un peu le faire plus vite si
bien fait mais ça c'est une haute idée
simple facile qu'on peut faire dans les
prochains mois qui vont nous au moins
nous permettre de ressortir de cette
pandémie la mieux outillée pour faire
face à l'autre crise qui essaient de
déchargement climat ça m'apparaît comme
une idée qui est somme toute assez
simple à comprendre on dirait c'est pas
compliqué de thé de dire leurs acquis en
un carte blanche porte l'investissement
public
c'est sur ce qu'on veut oui tout le
monde est d'accord qu'on veut investir
ou qu'on voit injecter cet argent là
dans les infrastructures somme c'est
quelque chose qui m'apparaît clair mais
c'est possible de créer un consensus
autour de ce match là avec toi cc c'est
la chose à faire
c'est bon pour l'économie c'est bon pour
l'environnement c'est oprah les plus
lointains il ya la question de
l'agriculture fida delà de
l'autosuffisance alimentaire l'exercice
et réduit le le trajet de nos aliments
on prépare les de télétravail ya dans le
télétravail une partie de la solution
pour diminuer la congestion notamment
est-ce que yopougon est ce qu'en
encourageant dans certaines
circonstances le télétravail on peut pas
faire ça que les gens se déplacent moins
il ya plein d'opportunités
il faut jeter saisir qu'il faut pas
laisser cette il faut pas laisser cette
opportunité le passé d'ailleurs il ya un
dicton en anglais que j'aime bien qui
dit never let good crisis goat weed faut
pas laisser les crises passées sous
notre nez sans s'en saisir comme d'une
opportunité
ça veut pas dire que la pandémie est une
bonne chose quand ça veut juste dire que
malgré la tragédie
il ya des opportunités d'autres paie ses
impôts comme changer la société
changement je pense que c'est laid les
fermes lufa qui font des débats nier bio
et qui les vaut porte qui expliquait que
ça prenait
les autres sont sur un toit ça prenait
ça leur prendra en fait trois fois les
infrastructures qui ont en ce moment
voir capable de nourrir montréal au
complet dans les po pour fournir des
paniers bio à moriat lot complet puis en
réflexion tu dis crème
c'est pas parce qu'une possibilité qui
est pas tant que ça m'apparaît comme
assez simple encore faisait sait pas
faire feu du tout ouais
puis il l'autosuffisance alimentaire
c'est une autre affaire qui qui me
parlent beaucoup les tice ce projet là
de me dire on n'a plus besoin on est
capable de manger local en cuisinant
avec ce qu'on a
selon les saisons puis oui des fois il y
aura pas d'avocat mais je suis en fait
dire ce moment puis l'avocat mais c'est
pas la fin du monde il ya un million
d'autres faits encore avec les serres on
peut faire plaisir
la technologie va continuer à évoluer on
va développer des salles de plus en plus
performantes
il y aura peut-être pas des avocats 12
mois par année tous pareils tous
parfaits mais je pense qu'il faut pas
non plus associer ces transformations là
avec un espèce de restriction d'un trou
de restriction ou d'ascétisme on a pas
besoin de venir des moines qui font voeu
de pauvreté foire il faut sortir sa de
l'attak
il ya des trucs qui sont un peu iodée
attentes qu'il faut falloir peut-être
réviser un petit peu à la bei ce genre
des mondes que tout le temps tu veux pas
vivre dans un monde je pense que s'il ya
des affaires qui songe aussi réaliste
mais mais faut arrêter de penser que ces
jeux ça veut dire qu'on va manger juste
dp théâtre des navets pis des grands
espoirs rire c'est faut sortir de la
technologie permet de faire plein de
choses intéressantes maintenant avec des
infrastructures de serre on pourrait
produire des légumes
à la vérité il ya des choses qui sont
passés bio d ce qu'il faut c'est juste
mettre l'énergie mettre l'argent c'est
ça que c'est peut-être mon beau de plus
politique mais on n'a pas un
gouvernement en ce moment qui comme très
intéressés par ces enfants lob sur tous
nos gouvernements qui est très
imaginatif ils ont beaucoup ce pilote
automatique sont beaucoup sur les
affaires simples de base comme on
faisait avant c'est pas un gouvernement
des pourparlers n'existe mikitenko trail
de boxe si on est vraiment un
malheureusement des gouvernés par des
gens qui sont en sont ceux de pilote
automatique sur le même vieux modèles
des fois j'ai l'impression que ça les
empêche de faire des affaires qui serait
bon pour le québec serait bon pour
l'économie
ce n'est pas si loin de leur idéologie
mais son son son sentiment sur le
concert mais à qui en fait c'est ici que
s'adresse à quelqu'un je me gêne c'est
peut-être un changement même si ces
changements il pousse ses filles unifab
le mans il des secteurs qui vont toucher
pieds des gens tout changement des idées
des gens qui vont en bénéficier et
d'autres qui d'autre au contrat kiki que
ça va lui nuire tipi je pense que
peut-être que la base de ce parti
politique les plus ancrés dans des
angles dans des industries qui qui qui
veulent moins de changements de ce qui
freine les banquiers
qui est vraiment de banquier si je dis à
françois legault vient d'arc transat
fait piaffer tribune qui nous laisse
l'économie c'est un banquier eric girard
mais des finances sur le banquier c'est
pas du monde simon qui viennent de
milieux où le modèle actuel justement
fermer ici des gens qui viennent de
milieux où les gens sont confortables
dans le monde actuel puis le toit les
changements climatiques on sent que ça
les salaires baissent à l'hectare aux
délices rendent bien compte que même du
point de vue des banques ça commence à
être un problème reconnaît m ils se
rendent compte qu'ils doivent changer
qui exagère mais on a un gouvernement
puis qui vient de milieux où les gens
constatent que ça va bien parizeau
l'ancien premier bec d'isère en 2012
dans la mobilisation étudiante disait
que l'esprit contre lequel les jeunes se
battaient à l'époque cet esprit là était
résumée par la fausse suivante y fait
chaud ça pue on est bien dirigé dix
dates constat mentalité-là la mentalité
de haut on est entre nous ça va bien on
change rien si des fois quand je vois le
gouvernement cette phrase ne me reviens
tu sais d'autres petits on parle depuis
dans tout le pouvoir de fait on tdp
tantôt on vante justement les les
pouvoirs les mérites du peuple mais on
dirait que s'il ya une manifestation on
sait les manifestations pour les climats
qui vit à montréal c'était immense
pondre excellent dans l'été dans condat
l'action suivante moins d'impact des
moins de changements mais la partie
yahia il y en aurait d'autres de prévus
l'an en mars pendant avril la
mobilisation paie les jeunes y avait des
mêmes des jours de grève de prévu dans
les cégeps les universités puis la
pandémie a cassé sa mobilisation à la
solide
pittet rappelez-vous le havre sarradet
il y en a comme 12 en janvier il a eu la
rentrée parlementaire le gouvernement
est un répit 2020 y'avait 2020 sera
l'année de l'environnement l'interaction
y avait quand même et puis moi si je
pense que c'était un résultat de cette
magnifique et parce que je n'avais
jamais entendu françois legault ou
l'aquarium de québec parler de
changement climatique et d'environnement
comme s'il n'y avait même pas prononcer
le mot durant la campagne électorale
et là il y avait annoncé que la nouvelle
priorité pour 2020 c'est l'environnement
ça pour moi c'était un résultat clair de
la mobilisation là haut on n'a pas pu
savoir si c'était sincère au système
juste de la com ça serait partial p mais
là avec le retour à quai la normale on
va pouvoir voir de quel bois il se
chauffe
c'est quand même des changements majeurs
à proposer c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
motive je dirais en ligne pour portneuf
pour faire elles ont fait 1 181 complet
pied ou en 98 complet puis on s'en va
dans une autre direction
à partir de maintenant c'est me serais
tout à fait content que ça arrive mais
j'ai je peux vraiment comprendre
pourquoi c'est le genre de chose qui
fait peur aux gentils le changement fait
toujours parler c'est sûr et certain
le changement fait pas ça c'est vrai pis
c'est vrai de tous les changements
puis surtout dans une position quitte
avantage c'est sopi après il ya une
responsabilité les gens qui sont en
position de pouvoir c'est moi je je
m'attends pas à ce que de même atteint
98 % des québécoises et des québécois
soit comme la lutte aux changements
climatiques
c'est la priorité de ma vie je vais
changer chacun de mes gestes
maintenant je suis zéro déchet dans le
jeu fait faire un 180 à l'ensemble de
mon existence
ça se passe pas comme ça ça se passe
jamais comme ce soit ce jeu mais penser
comme ça moi j'ai pas cette attente la
religion mais les gens ponction pouvoir
après deux baisses est ce que c'est le
plus ingrat parce qu ayant des
responsabilités plus grandes
parce que y ont plus de pouvoir les gens
à la tête des entreprises bien sûr
surtout les gens à la tête de nos
gouvernements c'est pas du monde comme
les eaux c'est pas vrai toit pas les
mêmes responsabilités que les autres
étaient lus tôt plus de responsabilités
c'est le leadership d'espèces de mots
qu'on n'utilise même là toutes les
soldats il faut que ça veut dire ça dans
les moments de crise de prendre des
responsabilités
puis de poche juste dire aux gens d
affaires faciles d afrique le monde veut
l'entendre des affaires qui conforte les
gens dans leurs habitudes dans leur
confort le leadership c'est être capable
d fois de dire des choses qui dérangent
les gens puissent assez ce qui bloque
beaucoup de politiciens d'haïti
des agents de changement dans le code e
de la lutte climatique c'est qu'ils
savent très bien que les changements
qu'il faut faire pour relever le défi
ça nécessite des branlées livre ça
nécessite deux confrontées certaines
certitudes
ça nécessite de mettre ou de bousculer
le confortement c'est ce qui fait en
sorte que ya tellement d'hommes
politiques tant politiques qu'ils font
papy qui plie parce qu'ils savent que ça
implique je devrais pas une
confrontation mais un face à face avec
l'électorat le montrant ses seins pas
facile
puis c'est un truc au quotidien quand il
fait la politique que tout ça sur ces
enjeux est ce que je veux plaire au
moment où est ce que je veux leur dire
la vérité que la vérité des voix impôts
toujours plaisant qui - ils ont froid
pas cette transformation loge juste par
le bas il va falloir que le montant au
top que le monde qui ont des
responsabilités politiques
rien de la responsabilité puis accepte
de dire aux gens d affaires qui dérange
est un paradoxe parce que c'est pour
pouvoir faire ces changements le doigté
lui tout il faut plaire puis en même
temps il faut bousculer ses sept plus
grands paradoxes des policiers qui s'est
tu viens de le résumer il faut il faut
plaire pour changer les choses il faut
être élu
merde quoi pour changer les choses à
grande échelle pour changer les choses
pour être élu pour être élu il pourrait
être élu ou réélu il faut plaire aux les
changements climatiques sap la percée
ces sites des décisions
qui vont déplaire comment on sort c'est
quoi ces dessus cl mettons ce serait
quoi l'idée qui permet de sortir de ce
que si je savais c'est ça parce que ma
nature bienveillante que je quitterai
cette question largue la démocratie si
on larry la démocratie mais yo deyo
débit tant que le gist sont rendus là
qu'ils disent
le problème avec le kit avec le culte
dont on vient de parler c'est la
démocratie
à partir du moment où on débarrasse la
démocratie crise on met les
scientifiques au pouvoir peu règle le
problème c'est extrêmement dangereux
puis moi je refuse de me rendre là mais
c'est quoi la solution pour sortir du
cul de sac
je les possibles à l'hiver dernier qui
s'appelle l'aide d'un député qui impulse
devrait bientôt chapitre sur cette
question de comment on sort de ce
cul-de-sac démocratique qui j'ai pas la
réponse mais j'y pense
paquin tous les jours mais c'est sûr
c'est sûr est ce qu est ce que là la
solution même si ce que tu nous as et
que là elle la solution passait vers le
haut mais les deux les deux ouais mais
est ce que on la vraie la réelle
question c'est ce que ça passe pas par
l'élection éventuelle de quelqu'un qui
ou d'un parti qui prône déjà ses idées
le spectre
la question c'est comment se passe le
mot qui va être réélu malgré les
changements qui vont déranger certaines
personnes on dirait que la seule façon
que je vois que ça sort de ce que si la
mentalité pas par le bas change assez
pour qu'elle devienne plus là pour que
ces idées là deviennent populaires
exactement c'est exactement je pense que
possiblement que on va le voir arriver
c'est de notre vécu ce qui va être
autant je veux pas voir leur d'hugo
pessimiste mais pour moi ça c'est le
dilemme de la poule ou l'oeuf tout parce
que les mentalités des gens là ils sont
aussi influencés puis formés parce que
les gens en position d'autorité dit
donc pendant faisant un parallèle un peu
boiteux local premier ministre du québec
10 ans nos pauvres assistés mais c'est
sûr qu'à persisterait sondages ce moment
que tu devras c'était mes possibilités
que ce que le premier se dit influencé
un peu le monde a bien sûr of course
donc c'est vraiment la poule ou l'oeuf
on aura pas de gouvernement qui vont
être résolument active dans la lutte aux
changements climatiques 100 kg et une
transformation des mentalités
mais peut-il y avoir une transformation
d'un verdict sans leadership qui vient
du haut puis quand les kanjis les deux
chiffres je peux dire autorités je veux
dire de d'inspirer lige les grandes
figures politiques de notre histoire pic
dans la plupart des démocraties sait
déjà qu'ils font pas juste prendre les
gens où ils sont c'est déjà qu'ils sont
capables d'élever le mans qui te pas
juste des jeux vous conforte dans des
idées que vous avez déjà mais je je je
je vous introduire des nouvelles idées
puis je vous amène appuyer ces idées-là
cc sol le leadership politique selon moi
donc c'est pour moi c'est vraiment la
police il va falloir les deux il faut
bien sûr que les mentalités changent
pour que le changement politique arrive
mais c'est pour moi les verts c'est vrai
aussi le changement politique ça aide à
faire évoluer les mentalités
les deux pays comment faire en sorte que
ces deux trucs là avance en même temps
c'est seul l'énorme défi qu on opine
mois comme personne qui fait de la
politique qui est obsédé par la question
des changements climatiques
je pense tous les jours comment trouver
cet équilibre la honte pour brusquer les
gens mais en même temps essayer des jeux
pas dire d élever la part ça voudrait
dire un peu que et qui sont comme plus
beau que moi mais de l'est de les
introduire à de nouvelles idées p-dg de
les aider à aspirer à autre chose parce
que c'est seulement du grand projet de
société c'est quoi ce quoi faire rêver
les gens mais c'est à dire en ce moment
vous êtes là qui mois joue j'essaie de
vous permettre de voir qu'il est hors
champ
autre chose qu est ce qui est possible
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire ensemble
ça c'est extrêmement de trouver cet
équilibre
j'ai le feeling que parce que ce que tu
décris laisse une certaine influence de
de l'instance gouvernementale de qui
permet de jeu majid influencé la pensée
public
j'ai l'impression que cette influence
leur temps à perdre un petit peu en
pouvoir puis surtout pour les plus
jeunes générations qui maintenant sont
j'imagine beaucoup plus influencée par
coton cours des influenceurs que au sens
très large censée relancer ces termes
que par les gouvernements j'imagine que
cette idée love ou ce projet là est
capable de se faire transmettre par de
quoi être beaucoup plus alternatifs que
par un point de presse du premier
ministre ou par une vision c'est joseph
prétend le premier ministre qui dit pour
reprendre l'analogie que fait tout à
l'heure qui dicte pas de racisme
systémique
il n'y a pas perçu aliotti a réussi à
faire à faire dire ça beaucoup de monde
le petit je faisais tout le monde après
ça dépend dans quel milieu c'est
effectivement problème est que ce n'est
pas dans ma bulle ou cissé qui
apprécient une fois qu'ils se rétractent
qui se rétractent m'inquiéter je pense
que c'est ça ma rétracter méfaits qui
crée un comité c'est un peu une sorte de
la tractation c'est peut-être finalement
il est peut-être un problème si c'est
comme ça a pris pourquoi ça prend
d'autres tu soulèves pour que pour que
pour que tu choisisses termine comme ça
c'est pourquoi tu côtoies leader c'est
mais moi je pense que c'est là la
distinction à faire de dire le leader
peut-être qui est ailleurs peut-être
qu'il faut regarder ailleurs pour pour
élire pour avoir un bassin qui va élire
des idées progressistes comme ça mais tu
vois c'est vraiment que c'est pour moi
la question que tu poses sellaband parce
qu'il ya un rôle dit les influents sorte
je mettais mon chapeau de cela que
j'irai la culture au sens large
les médias sociaux le la culture hakem
tout à fait très large tout ce qui se
passe dans la sphère culturelle de la
société
ces affaires lui le son super importante
pour le changement social
il ya pas de changement social sans que
des artistes des influenceurs déjà dans
les médias fassent évoluer les
mentalités ouvre les esprits anime les
débats c'est essentiel le défi c'est
comment au transfert cette énergie là
comment le haut-lac analyse pour que ça
devienne du changement politique que le
risque qui les médias sociaux pour moi
c'est ça alimente serait ça augmente ce
risque-là c'est que ce bouillonnement
culturel reste dans cette sphère halle
puis qu'on reste chacun dans notre bulle
convaincu qu'on est en train de changer
le monde parce que quand notre fils du
cru pensent comme moi ça va piquer
pendant ce temps là les gens qui
gouvernent pour vrai qu'ils votent les
lois pour vrai soit son âge ne doit
déranger moi donc il faut que ce cette
ébullition l'eau social kiwi est plus
forte que jamais à cause des médias
sociaux puis oui c'est vrai chez les
jeunes la voie d'un françois legault va
avoir pas mal moins d'influx ans
probablement que d'autres voix
auxquelles ils vont avoir accès dans la
dans la sphère culturelle
il faut que il fasse le pont de l'un à
l'autre
à partir de ce qu'ils voient comme idée
de temps dans speed de mouvement dans
son livre sur les médias sociaux ou avec
leurs amis comment est ce qu on canalise
sa presse avant le shampooing uniquement
parce que sinon c'est le risque d'une
d'une espèce de division où il va y
avons des microbulles très progressiste
très branchouille tout ça dans les
villes beaucoup un pic pendant ce temps
là soit sa vie indépendamment d'un monde
politique qui est encore contrôlée par
la même génération par les mêmes idées
et qui on remet le même monde au pouvoir
sur moi je vous le dis je le sens des
fois ce risque là c'est des jeunes
ça m'est arrivé après la dernière
élection jean mi octobre 2018 une bande
de jeunes qui vient boire à salut
gabriel fauré
on est tellement contents genre de votre
avancée on vous a suivi sur instagram
toute la campagne d'ailleurs vous êtes
comme je le seul
très cool avec ses contacts vous avez pu
voter pour la première fois à wayne ont
finalement on n'est pas allé on n'a pas
pu te gêne m'a dit on est content
j'avais dix députés n'est même pas les 6
comment on transfère cette énergie le
support je suis par contre j'suis pas
cool gains hier la qui partager c'est
top
le capa doit faire le juste le dilemme
de plus de la liberté plus chemin pas en
train d'aller te demander d'aller dans
trois manifs par voilà juste aller voter
c'est ce que je veux dire d'en
transférer cette énergie la dent dans
des gestes politiques qui peuvent
changer qui nous gouvernent
parce que sinon le risque c'est celui de
la bulle est dépendante pic la structure
les gîtes et les structures politiques
et encore légitimité et les cultures de
plus en plus homogène petit je te lancer
les jeunes dans général qui ont été
influencés maintenant pour nous de
l'information qui vient prendre partout
mais d'aller voter
trier au quebec community parler de coût
quand c'est dur commun c'est maintenant
aux états unis trump se pose beaucoup à
la réforme des votes le tripot parce que
lui de faire sortir les votes c'est
parce qu'ils veulent être aimés
c'est fou comme 1 en 2020 on est encore
à se dire faut demander au monde de
sortir de chez eux d'aller faire la file
métier c'est vraiment plus facile que ça
à l'air puis de voter
physiquement j'ai l'impression que si on
se disait et ont tout le monde
méthode de vote dans nos poches on a une
méthode de vote dans nos poches le tir
ça pourrait clairement être facile
admettons le séquestre sécurité mais ce
n'est pas un défi qui me semblait really
possible facile mater facilement
l'ascendant leur entente au téléphone tu
fais me demande tu reçois de 1000 pièces
d'eau jours après tout comme c'est ici
y c'est une question de sécurité
associés puis on le fait c'est
facilement et des âmes et on sait que
import ou android sont capables
d'envoyer des notifications d'alarm à
tout moment fait que le cette journée le
hand ces horloges gauche au début lors
que tu veux le tuteur soit un tourin à
l'ail puis tu remplis ton sur ton
y a plein la faction moi je vois ça je
me dis tu veux tu veux faire sortir tout
les votes pour avoir la meilleure après
parce que parce que ces pauvres et que
tout les démographies sont également
représentés lors du vote
c'est pas vrai les taux de participation
sont super variables sont exactement
exactement ce sera exactement puis
certaine génération va voter plus d'un
côté certaines pilotées ont cessé
lesquels fait moins dans ma tête c'est
c'est incompréhensible que ce qui limite
une réelle démocratie ce soit la volonté
d'un individu à sortir de chez lui pour
aller voter
moi ça fait pas de sens pour moi je
comprends pas pourquoi tu je suis
d'accord avec toi qu'il faudrait que ce
soit plus facile pire plein de manières
de le rendre plus facile en effet
détruit david en année des petits
changements genre permettent de voter
sur ton campus était un cégépien
l'université mcc pour y est bon c'est
pas le pérou mais repris mais après
c'est eh oui le rendre plus facile mais
en nettement moins des fois je vois du
monde pc c'est vraiment parce qu'ils
pensent que c'est pas important puisque
même si c'était plus facile je passerai
qui trouverait sa plus importante qui
l'associé le cl c'est ce qu'on disait
tantôt c'est si oui il faut que ce soit
plus facile mais il faut que le monde
comprenne que c'est c'est important
puisque les changements sociaux auxquels
is aspect parce que moi c'est ce que je
remarque le monde même quand ils votent
pas il ya des trucs qui me dérange mais
tout à fait ce soir non des opinions
bien des trucs qui va le changer
c'est juste le lien de phares de le lien
j'ai des insatisfactions
gd
des rêves des projets de société peut
pas pour que ça ça se matérialise et un
geste que je peux frapper moi c'est ce
pont là des fois que je vois des gens
super engagé super informé ce pôle qui
existe entre les deux ce j'avoue moi ça
me rend de ses compères du foie
l'institution y croit putté télé famille
disque aux autocars et lui où il attend
encore p ils pensent vraiment là que
c'est pas vraiment ce qui change le
monde moi ou je fais autre chose
j'achète l'oqaj fait si je partage des
trucs du contenu ce médecin ce pays
pense vraiment que c'est plus important
que changer qui nous gouvernent
parce qu'ils ont intégré le disco un
certain discours qui dit que les
changements sociaux de toute façon ça
passe par les gouvernements ça passe par
les gens qui changent d'habitude
évidemment moi je trouve que c'est d'une
c'est une erreur grave de penser qu'il
faut faire un hulot - 500 contacts
quelle drôle de dilemme comme tout
facilement faire les deux mais en fait
c'est la seule manière que ça change
faire les deux mais moi c'est cette
opposition là je la trouve en fait je la
trouve stupide jeu depuis on n'a pas
besoin de choisir entre deux on peut
faire les deux je peux faire toutes les
changements il faut faire tous les
changements nécessaires dans notre vie
personnelle et fassent qu'on peut pour
changer qui nous gouvernent
on n'a pas besoin de choisir on peut
faire les deux pays c'est la seule mana
que les choses changent dis moi c'est ce
que je vois plus ça s'abîme chercher les
gens qui me disent oui nos métiers on
s'aimerait beauté beauté mégarde moi je
pense que j'ai plus d'influencé s'ils
changent la fois dans ma vie voyons je
pense de poche n'a pas besoin de choisir
entre les deux admettons qu'on veut
illustrer de la façon la plus claire
l'importance de qui gouverne
c'est facile de dire imaginons un
gouvernement majoritaire la caq
gouvernement majoritaire québec
solidaire
imaginez deux mondes différents dans
lesquels on vit de ce que je fais pas
regarder regarde où se réunira en trunk
c'est ça que j'aime dit clinton mind qui
entendent pour qui j'avais un
enthousiasme égal à mon enthousiasme en
vrai
le golf c'est même à se hisser comme
c'est quand même pas serment mais c'est
pas le même en on n'en vit pas dans le
même monde où tout est même juste plus
parce qu'on l'a vu le monde avec obama
puis le monde avec 35 chose complément
différent pycharm quitté obama clinton
ces gens là c'est pas des
révolutionnaires le nom exact quand même
pas trompé 1 ces choses pis le jour où
on est et où tu réalises que le fait de
poids par exemple pour ce faire pour une
femme de pouvoir se faire avorter ou pas
que ça peut reposer sur qui a gagné les
anciens puisque ces choses de se mettre
vraiment en danger
comme dans le cas d'élection de
chanteuse là ça devient très gros gains
concrets d'un très concret tout d'un
coup très concret je veux avoir avant
qu'on se dit je veux qu'on parle un
petit peu la situation allait ch et
celle des à laquelle on est on était
confrontés dernièrement où est ce qu'on
sait aussi ce trou était fait mais dans
le viseur c'est fait mais on s'est fait
mettre dans le visage vraiment un défaut
fondamental du traitement qu'on qu'on
fait nos aînés de la façon avec laquelle
notre société a mis en place cette façon
de fonctionner là de tout mettre nos
aînés dans des centres comme celui là
comment chez que tu avais fait un vidéo
j'ai trouvé super intéressant sur ou est
ce qu'on allait comme on en était rendu
là ces puits pour les gens qui nous
écoutent qui ont pas entendu ceux qui se
demandent pas taille comment on s'est
rendu le sais quoi qui s'est passé pour
qu'on s'en rende ses plus belles
synthétiser tutu le partagera dans les
commentaires de du podcast vidéo là
parce que j'ai beaucoup de commentaires
postés parce que celles qui sont donc
j'essaie de répondre
comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là ça
ne s'est pas tombée du ciel
c'est par hasard pourquoi pied pourquoi
au québec plus qu'ailleurs big three on
pourrait faire un truc
ensemble là dessus mais consomment a
doté ce qu'on a fait depuis les années
90 au québec
bon d'abord là on a à partir des années
90 c'est le début de ce qu'on appelle le
néolibéralisme l'obsession de 17,0 la
der c'est là qu'on s'est mis nous
augmentons notre génération depuis qu'on
suit un peu la politique c'est le seul à
peu près un dc10 cocon entame on est
trop endetté le québec en europe et
rotax on paie trop d'impôts et un
déficit il faut couper il faut couper il
faut couper faut payer pour nous pour
notre génération puis pour le maquis des
gens qui nous écoutent des bonnes
chansons dans la mine a raison pour nous
ce discours là c'est ce qu'on entend par
les politiciens
depuis qu'on nous la bonne nouvelle mais
c'est pas au discours toujours x les
escrocs qui apparaît grosso modo dans
les années 90 ça apparaît en même temps
peu partout dans le monde ce mouvement
qui s'appelle le néolibéralisme où l'on
se met à dire l'état ça coûte trop cher
les services publics c'est trop tôt
lucien bouchard au québec est un des
grands tenant de ce discours là et dans
les années 90 ans mais a commencé à
couper à couper à couper bien avoir une
grande grève des infirmières à la fin
des années 90 d'ailleurs à cause de ça
et l'on commence une longue descente aux
enfers où on veut couper énormément dans
le réseau de la santé et où on va en
parallèle de coupe et on va centraliser
les autres quand on a créé le réseau de
la santé publique
ce supplice dans les années 60 mais
plusieurs centaines d'établissements de
santé répond laveur réseau de la santé
très décentralisé puis le meilleur
exemple de socialistes des fonds et
célèbre clc en avait partout
teddy tissier les seins c'était donc un
réseau public mais décentralisée partout
sur le territoire et à partir des années
90 vraiment très facile d'accès très
facile d'accès puis on se met à
centraliser aujourd'hui là et les
chiffres sont là dans mon esprit mais on
en a moins d'une quinzaine non pendant
moins d'une trentaine d'établissements
de santé au québec
donc on est passé d'un système très
décentralisé à un énorme système ultra
centralisé dont des mastodontes
bureaucratique et en plus on a coupé
donc on a moins d'argent dans le système
d énormes str
et la portion de l'argent qu'on met en
santé qui va dans les soins du monde a
diminué
qu'est ce qui a augmenté pendant ce
temps la caisse qui gruge une partie
toujours plus grand de l'argent
commerçante et le salaire des médecins
qui lui a explosé dans les dernières
décennies
donc on a un système que de moins en
moins de moyens qui est de plus en plus
gros plus en plus centralisée c'est plus
en plus des énormes machines dont c'est
la moitié humain c'est moins humain - de
proximité la part qu'ils vont faire des
médecins a explosé puis la part aussi
qui vaut aux médicaments ce soit d'autre
à faire que dans la vidéo d'art dont je
parle pas mais s'annonce très
intéressante quand on crée la santé
publique le le réseau santé publique au
québec
la portion du budget qui s'en vont
médicaments c'est pourquoi 5% en ce
moment c'est vrai pour ça ça ça augmente
le salaire des médecins en mouvement
donc la portion du budget qui va en
soins est de plus en plus petit donc
c'était pas impossible à prévoir
c'était aussi un choc sur le système on
est de la misère dans la mesure où ça
fait des années qu'on met moins d'argent
qu'on centralise et que l'argent qu'on
bien senties voit de moins en moins dans
les soins mais de plus en plus dans les
poches de médecins mg kg en médicaments
et ajoutez à ça au fait que le
gouvernement fédéral qui avant
transférer plein d'argent aux provinces
pour financer l'aide de la santé il
s'est mis en transfert est de moins en
moins
donc tu mets tous ensemble sur trente
ans que ça soit une pandémie ou un autre
choc un système aussi affaiblie tu
donnes jeunes qu ils vacances épilogue à
caen c'est pas vrai est ce qu'il y avait
durant tout ce processus là des
whistleblowers du monde qui qui voyait
sa ré qui disait avoir ce que je peux
comprendre que peut-être qu'on se posait
à la distribution des du budget mai 2010
si jamais
c'est pour casser ça va casser pour vrai
pour telle ou telle ou telle raison
puis il ya des gens qui disent depuis
des années en 2015
quand les gouvernements libéral e coupé
30 % 30 % d'un coup dans le budget de la
santé publique
donc le truc d'eau à horacio arruda est
le patron la prévention en santé la
santé publique
tout le monde le dit c'est une erreur un
camp au québec avant on faisait nos
propres vaccins
publié il ya un truc qui s'appelle
institut armand frappier qui produisait
des des vaccins ici au québec on va
donner aux entreprises privées pour vous
envoyer ça dans les pays étrangers
tandja qui ont dit onesta
si une pandémie puisqu'il faut faire nos
propres vaccins on pourra pas ces
avertissements lyon était une pie il y
avait des politiciens qui avait un
agenda politique très claire très simple
c'était il faut absolument équilibrer le
budget cette année ou en photo ici la
prochaine élection moto et et le jeu et
le la fin justifie les moyens
donc s'il faut couper en santé publique
on va le faire s'il faut couper dans le
siège ce dont on va le faire s'il faut
rendre aussi fort envoyé des infirmières
comme on le fait à la fin des années 90
on va le faire puis cette obsession là à
nous à nous ont coûté des milliers de
vies dans les derniers mots ses choix
politiques lois qui nous ont mené là
c'est voter pendant le double effet
acheté j'avais vu je pense qu'à un
moment il y avait fait le montage de
toutes les fois où une nouvelle
il parlait de à quel point le nom mais
quel point la fth et celle des les
conditions sont tracés piste tout avec
bernard derome des 90 est l'élu nokia
être vient de dévoiler une condition ch
et celles d'essence on se sont vraiment
pas optimale les gens un bain par
semaine les gens au sipi les gens se
plaît elle ne retire ce qui tu voyais
les années les annales année puis à
chaque fois qu'on en parle puis tu vois
ça a pris ce pour que finalement on
écoute le message qu'ont qui avait été
répété plusieurs fois ces débiles cdb
que ça va continuer parce que même moi
aussi je me rappelle entendent se tient
dans des histoires de
un bain par semaine je me rappelle le
seul et vrai tyran qui était juste pas
capable de fournir on le sait depuis
tellement longtemps
ces légendes et plus ça fait partie les
années surtout les aînés les plus
vulnérables qui sont enrichis celle des
fais partie des gens les plus fragiles
de notre société tpiy pour prendre un
cliché épouvantable mais vrai comme le
foie le sont parfois certains clichés tc
souvent dans la manière dont on traite
les plus vulnérables dans société convoi
de qu'on ait faite
puis c'est honteux c'est honteux la
manière dont on prend soin où on prend
pas soin de ses aînés au québec qu'il a
le pays dans tout ça c'est qu'on la
connaît la solution fait des années
qu'on sait pour les aînés spécifiquement
ça fait des années qu'on le sait que la
solution c'est de de prendre l'argent
comme qu'on investit pour mettre les
jambes en 80 dans des institutions de
soins puis prendre l'argent là puis le
rediriger vers les soins de missiles
ouais faire en sorte que au lieu que la
personne s'en aille dans un hôpital ou
dans un centre de soins
quand même tu as même les soins des
personnes isolées non seulement c'est
démontré par à peu près de tulle plus
aux casseurs que c'est meilleur pour la
santé mentale la santé physique des gens
c'est aussi démontré que ça coûte moins
cher ça coûte moins cher offre on voit
économiser l'eau qu'est vraiment aucune
raison de le faire
c'est pour vous donner une idée de la
planète sur laquelle on vit à quel point
ce une planète différente dans la
plupart des pays européens
la proportion du budget pour les aînés
qui va en soins à domicile 60 70 80 %
puis le reste va pour les soins dont
l'institution
nous ici 15% à koné dans une proportion
un grand qu'il est mans est versée puis
là je vous dis pas ça c'est en ce moment
ça qu'on est en ce moment parmi les
pires au monde tous les pays dans le
monde l'ont compris je veux prendre soin
des vieux tous les gardes à la maison le
plus longtemps possible qui y arrive un
moment où ils sont trop mal en point
trop magané trop balade dans les cantons
où l'autre
semaine 1 sûr mais plus on garde nos
aînés chez eux
mieux ils vont être tous les
spécialistes le disent dans le monde
tous les pays dans le monde
le fond on est une des exceptions allez
y en a pas de défaite il y en a pas d'
excuses pour dire qu'on le savait pas
on le sait très bien depuis des années
les gouvernements l'ont été parce qu'ils
ont manqué de vision métier une
réflexion aussi que chacun doit avoir
piqué personnelle et collective sur
comment contrer les années dans nos
sociétés étaient justice quand même bien
et quand même un choix de société
vraiment un choix de dire je place mes
parents dans une institution répit c'est
ça bouleverse pas la fermeture
judiciaire
on en parlait avec maïté saganash tpiy
là le rapport qu'ils années chez
communauté autochtone est complètement
différente et beaucoup plus intégrer la
famille de cépie on peut s'en inspirer
c'est vraiment quelque chose à ce jeu là
dedans active ou le gouvernement de
prendre action mais je pense que on doit
aussi collectivement réfléchira c'est
quoi c'est quoi être année c'est quoi
c'est quoi la place qu'on la regarde en
société de cépie tout à fait stupide
dans les cultures du monde
autant de cultures que de pecs de
perception pi2
de valorisation non du rôle des aînés et
aussi des cultures où on les abandonne
pour les laisser dans l'histoire du
métayer aussi des cultures d'abandonner
un certain âge on laisser mourir les
gens donc t on it
encore une fois on n'est ni il ya des
cultures bien pires que la nôtre il y en
a aussi bien meilleurs dont on peut
s'inspirer
c'est de bien résoudre il ya aussi une
question culturelle d'une question
sociale là j'essaie d'être optimiste là
dedans parce que on le fait le même
trajet pour les enfants c'est tout l'art
tout le progrès qu'on a fait sur la
conciliation travail famille
depuis les années 80 sur le fait qu' il
fallait mettre en place des institutions
petits mécanismes pour que les gens
surtout les femmes puissent à la fois
travailler et être parents on a mis des
mécanismes en place des programmes comme
la le régime québécois d'assurance
parentale les congés parentaux ont cédé
est important et on a mis les mécanismes
en place pour qu'on peut pas faire la
même chose pour les aînés
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait pas en temps
mais la même réflexion qui doit bon
comment on fait pour être à la fois
travailleurs et enfin de nous de nos
parents qui sont rendus dans la
troisième manche comment on fait pour
sans sacrifier la vie professionnelle
parce que c'est souvent ça la friction
comment ça s'écrit prophète la vie
professionnelle prendre davantage soin
de nos parents ou de nos parents sens
large qui sont des années et clément
lefert propos les moeurs pour les bears
on est capable de le faire et on a
inventé des intentions des mécanismes
pour faire ça si en 1930 avait dit que à
un jour il va avoir un truc où les
employeurs et des travailleurs et met de
l'argent dans un pote
puis quand un pape a eu un enfant il y
reçoit comme une partie de son salaire à
travail sur pattes l'api arrêtent de
travailler sept personnes menaçant de
prendre un travailleur en tenant de quoi
tu passes c'est du délire
on a inventé ces enfants là parce qu'on
a décidé que c'était important même si
on travaille de s'occuper de nos enfants
moi je pense qu'il faut avoir le même
parcours eu la même réflexion dans les
prochaines années avec les années parce
que c'est souvent ce qui empêche les
gens prendre soin des années c'est
l'effet que jobs
tu peux pas aller voir ta mère à tous
les dossiers chez toi tu ne peux pas
prendre tous les jours si tu travailles
pas comment on peut inventer des
affaires des mécanismes des institutions
pour concilier les deux surtout que
c'est un problème qui passeront petit
hall de la population vit avec les
bébé-boumeurs tombe à la retraite et
compagnie les gens vont vivre de plus en
plus longtemps c'est donc le modèle
actuel qui dit que quand ces gens-là
perte de l'autonomie
le premier réflexe est de les mettre en
institution ça va d'une part ça va faire
ça pourra construire des des
institutions ans malade ça va être un
gouffre financier
épouvantable ce modèle l'oiea notamment
à cause du vieillissement la population
y voit l'échec
il faut trouver un autre modèle qui va
être quelque chose comme un mélange de
soins domicile et d'implication du xixe
est de nous comme citoyen comme
citoyenne comme enfant ou comme neveu
comme nice ou comme cousin comme cousine
de de prendre soin aussi deux autres il
va falloir que les gouvernements nous a
aidé à concilier parce qu'on doit pas
que le monde arrête de travailler
puisque les femmes retournent au foyer
pour s'occuper des grands parents alors
qu'on vient dé sortir du foyer à grâce à
la conscience autres infamies fait
comment on va trouver une solution
moi je pense que c'est un magnifique
chantier il ya plein d'idées dangereux
imaginez pour faire ça parce qu'il va
falloir les deux des choix politiques
pic des choix individuels
parce qu'on pourra plus se fier sur des
actions pour prendre soin de nos vieux
il y en eut ni dangereux qui va prendre
toute la journée le gars mais il ya un
sujet une idée dangereuse qui circule
beaucoup plus le je mets des guillemets
a dangereusement en ce moment antibes on
parlait justement de soulèvement
populaire puis d'idées justement qui se
transmettaient avec les réseaux sociaux
de succès avec les mouvements
antiracistes ans en ce moment un slogan
qu'on attend beaucoup si d'iphones
police me prendre les fonds qui seraient
alloués à aux corps policiers puis les
mettre dans des services sociaux dans
notre ressource alternative que la
police doit cette idée là est ce que tu
penses que transposable au québec parce
que je pense qu'il est légitime et
pertinents mais elle et elle est
transposable en partie au québec
il faut quand même faire une principale
précision faut savoir qu aux états-unis
pic on voit les images de manifestations
le voilier la police la défense de la
police et l'armée souvent et edward m
la table ronde et un creusement c'est du
délire il ya des villes de 10000
habitants qui ont des swapping c'est du
délire c'est vrai notamment parce qu'il
ya eu des progrès sous obama est sous
chiang mai qui ont commencé sous
vêtements de 30 du vieux matériel de
l'armée puis de les donner ou de les
vendre à rabais à des pas des
départements de police a permis à du
tout petit département de police de
sécurité comme comme ça dans la gueule
quoi exactement comme les marines
carrément donc le slogan de défendre de
police aux états unis qu'il il y aussi à
ce phénomène là qu'on appelle des fois
la militarisation de la police c'est un
phénomène aussi peau dure l'aller les
forces policières qui ont vu leurs
budgets explosent et pour se doter
d'armes et de gadgets et d'équipements
guerriers des l'iran y est mal investi
il faut qu'une bonne partie cet argent
là c'en a aidé ans dans les communautés
pour traiter les problèmes sociaux
d'autre manière et avec des gains de
swat et moi j'essaie je comprends en
tout cas c'est mon interpellation de ce
slogan là aussi dans ce contexte
américain plus là dessus on va se le
dire le québec est pas ma place des yo
yo yo le phénomène la militarisation la
police ça existe en partie chez nous
mais son prix au québec ça existait dans
quelques services de police les plus
gros ou pâte est des fois il ya un peu
d'excès monde et quand même pas dans le
dérapage et le délire total com aux
etats-unis
longtemps quand même parler de
d'autochtones tué par les policiers
spécifier la question de défendre moitié
ya aussi au québec des petits services
de police qui ont très peu de moyens
mais j'ai eu ma cousine qui est
policière qui était policière aux
services de police de teufeurs mind et
qui me racontait t d un niveau de sous
financement vraiment chroniques ou les
policiers eux mêmes sont mal équipés
sont mal protégés donc il faut faire
attention avec ce slogan la kiki sur le
seconde interprétation qui est articulée
dans un contexte américain ou une orgie
de dépenses qui existe quand même un peu
mou québec ceci étant dit en dessous du
slogan d'iphones de police ya une grosse
question
ça sert à quoi la police est ce que
c'est la police qui devrait s'occuper
des problèmes sociaux ou est-ce que pas
d'autres mécanismes de décision qui
serait mieux placé pour s'occuper des
problèmes sociaux
pourquoi c'est la police qui s'occupe
des gens cela sur des différences est ce
que c'est ça le travail de la police
dans une société
ça c'est une question ultra personnes
presque fédéral
pourquoi est ce que c'est la police que
ce que déjà qu'un problème de
toxicomanie presse que c'est la police
que ce que des plaines de bruit as tu
besoin d'être un policier armé pour
s'occuper de zinc de brûler dans un
quartier une forêt y des gaps qui cette
remise en question l'ade qu'est ce qu'on
demande à la police qui skie vraiment
son mandat puis qu'est-ce qui est la
sécurité publique la gestion du vivre
ensemble qui devrait peut-être en effet
peut relever de la police puis où on
devrait avoir d'autres types de
ressources plus communautaire plus
sociale pour s'occuper des problèmes moi
cette réflexion nous battre au
extrêmement pertinente parce qu'en effet
on pourrait se demander c'est peut-être
même pas juste pour la police de lui
demander de s'occuper de ces choses
depuis moi j'ai entendu le témoignage de
police il qu'ils nous le disent elle dit
moi une personne en situation d'être
aussi un problème de santé mentale
puis de multi toxicomane il j'ai poli je
fais de mon mieux mais j'ai pas les
outils piles et pour m'occuper de
sapiens ont vainement ce commerçant qui
m'appelle alain j'ai encore une
itinérante dans mon parti vient
l'enlever où je peux obligé comme
policiers d'aller mais c'est mon boss me
demande comme pas le choix d'aller en
j'ai pas les outils pour leurs fans
et cette réflexion ressort à quoi ça
sert la police qu'est ce qu'on me
demande qu'est-ce qu'on devrait pas une
bande et puis qu'est-ce qu'on devrait
ajouter comme ressource à côté de la
police pour s'occuper d'autre chose
je la trouve extrêmement pertinente même
team même des comportements j'ai comme
comme criminaliser le team et on a une
communauté souffrent pauvreté ou
inspirés des problèmes de trafic de
drogue ou une cataracte et excuse est-ce
que c'est par la criminalisation puis
par là par l'olaf la répression la
répression puis par la punition puis par
l'incarcération que tu veux régler des
problèmes de fond comme ce j'en ai des
doutes
absolument mais pour moi la réponse sur
la chemise
projet plus que des deux ce modèle de
moto qu'on prend l'exemple la drogue on
a fait des épisodes
c'est la fameuse la guerre à la drogue
c'est là un des plus grand gaspillage de
fonds publics de l'histoire cette idée
qu'on veut lutter contre la toxicomanie
puis les usages de drogues par la
répression policière et la
criminalisation
c'est une erreur sur toute la ligne
une erreur qui nous coûte très cher
c'est un excellent exemple de job qu'on
donne à la police qu'on devrait
abandonner la police doit pas dire qu
que la consommation de drogue
c'est en tout temps banques auraient
c'est juste de dire est ce que ce monde
là la manière de les aider cela envoyer
les flics ou est-ce que pas d'autre
manière d aider plus d'ailleurs il ya
des modèles dans le monde notamment au
portugal où on a décriminalisé
l'ensemble des drogues et où notamment
la réduction des taux d'overdose est
absolument fantastique fait cette
réflexion là elle est super important
moi je trouve ça super le fun que le
mouvement black la smart est allé sur la
ramène pas c'est pas des nouvelles
questions mais la russie est devenue
ainsi la ramène au devant de la scène
qui
j'espère qu'on va avoir ce ce ce débat
là aussi au québec tu es est ce que
c'est normal à montréal court square
cabot là où on le sait une concentration
de gens tonnes se sont différence c'est
une normale ce soit que ces gens là les
gens qui voient le plus souvent cédé
police aucun sens kimo des x men je me
dis même un peu des policiers qui font
des abus piscine acceptable mais des
fois je le dis même un peu comme prof
policiers formés pour ça qu'ils nous
enverront se déresponsabilise comme
société parce qu'on coupe d'un service
socio politique occupez vous des
problèmes concrets
parce qu'on crée de la pauvreté avec
notre système économique on coupe des
services sociaux bien pression du
policier gérer le trône des fois même je
trouve que on les met dans une mauvaise
posture les principes des policiers en
leur demandant de faire une job laquelle
sont pas formés ce camp du sud pour une
seconde excuser les abus la répression
le profilage
je veux juste dire que on peut pas
sortir la critique des abus policiers de
son contexte qui est un contexte où on
crée de la pauvreté au tri de
l'exclusion qui on se donne pas de
ressources
en outre que la police pour s'en occuper
merci infiniment gazon messieurs c'était
une excellente diction vraiment les gens
très intéressants si facebook 100
épisodes plus tard exactement
merci messieurs